Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du, ich habe hier eine Nachricht von Gott erhalten und er ist offenbar nicht so glücklich, wie die Dinge laufen.
Ich höre den Klang des Regens im Überfluss, ich höre den Klang des Sieges. Ich höre den Klang von Ruf und Gesang, ich höre den Klang des Sieges. Ich höre den Klang des Regens im Überfluss, ich höre den Klang des Sieges. Ich höre den Klang.
Netzpolitik Nummer dreihundertsiebenundsechzig, wenn ich mich nicht täusche vom sechsten November zwanzig zwanzig und wir hören den Klang des Sieges.
Darauf haben wir uns doch schon lange gefreut. Den Klang des äh Klang des Regens und äh ja, all das zu hören.
Ja, ich glaube, ich habe das hier noch nie erzählt, aber ich habe ja als Teenager ein Jahr in den USA gelebt.
Und dort äh ähm eine ich glaube ungefähr ein halbes Jahr mit einer Familie, die in diesen ähm in diesen,
Christenkulten sich bewegte, diesen Pfingstheiligen, ja und äh da habe ich solche Performances äh jeden Sonntag und ich glaube, dienstags haben die mich da auch hingeschleift, über Stunden mir anschauen können.
Das war äh Wahnsinn beeindruckender Dämpfer.
Lass uns erstmal die Runde hier vorstellen, weil wir sind äh heute noch äh was heißt noch, wir sind zu dritt. Thomas ist nämlich auch noch im Kanal. Hallo.
Hallo, freut mich, da zu sein.
Ja, Grüße nach Wien und ja.
Es ist was in Wien passiert, aber darauf kommen wir später zu sprechen. Fangen wir mit der Welt an.
Genau, denn es ist ja auch was in den USA passiert oder auch noch nicht so richtig, je nachdem, wie man das jetzt so sieht. Wir waren ja hier letzte Woche. Eigentlich so ein bisschen in der Erwartung, dass wir äh heute am Freitag schon wüssten, woran wir denn so sind,
und stellt sich raus, wissen wir noch nicht.
Ja, aber das war doch, also das war doch tatsächlich absehbar, äh dass man das dass das Auszählen sich hinziehen würde, oder?
Ja, gut, da mag so jeder so seine eigene Erwartungshaltung gehabt haben. Ich persönlich hab's mir nicht so knapp vorgestellt, aber was soll's.
Umfragen glauben können, wäre es wüssten wir's jetzt schon, aber es ist eben nicht so eindeutig, wie vorhergesagt wurde, sondern es ist erschreckend.
Das ist schon schlechte Nachricht genug eigentlich, dass man
dass man sich heute noch, also es, es, es, es verhagelt den äh die diesen Erfolg, der ja nun doch sich abzeichnet, aber das ist wirklich keine
Also den wird man nicht unbedingt ähm feiern können in der Form, wie der jetzt verlaufen ist, ne?
Aber das wird uns nicht davon abhalten, die Champagnerflasche zu köpfen Linus. Äh ich habe da auch den richtigen Spruch äh letztens gefunden, so Invictory your tourfumping in the feed united, Napoleon Bonaparte.
So ich glaube an Napoleon Bonaparte wird uns noch einiges äh in den nächsten Wochen erinnern, oder?
Dass ich die Dinge ja sehr schnell ändern, sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz sagen, äh in welchen Zwischenstand wir jetzt hier gerade hineinkommentieren zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt sind auf Joe Biden, äh ungefähr dreiundsiebzig
dreiundsiebzig Millionen Komma sieben äh,
dreiundsiebzig Komma sieben Millionen Stimmen ähm entfallen und Trump liegt bei neunundsechzig Komma sechs.
Dass es jetzt sozusagen die Poppy Awarden, wir wissen natürlich alle, dass äh Rennen wird nicht dadurch entschieden, sonst wäre es schon lange entschieden
sondern es kommt eben auf diese komische Auszählung der einzelnen Staaten an mit und naja, deswegen muss halt jetzt noch der eine oder andere Start an
ähm Joe Biden bevor man hier sicher sein kann, dass er gewinnt, aber das ist,
jetzt gerade die allgemeine Erwartungshaltung. Und äh zumindest scheint die Daten diese Information auch schon bei Trump angekommen zu sein, weil der halt so öffentlich schon langsam anfängt zu schmelzen.
Ja, aber auch irgendwie so, was ich spannend finde oder was relevante Indikatoren für mich sind, ist so das Umfeld von ihm,
manche republikanischen Senatoren distanzieren sich so leicht schon von ihm oder machen Aussagen, die so in die Richtung gehen, dass man vorhat, das Wahlergebnis zu akzeptieren
was schön ist. Und ähm Fox News distanziert sich auch ein bissel mehr von ihm und äh,
nimmt irgendwie Staaten, die andere Networks noch nicht äh ausgezählt haben, callen sie und geben die an beiden, also,
da ist schon vielleicht so ein bissel emanzipation vom Bulli im Gange und die bereiten sich wahrscheinlich auch drauf vor, dass sie die nächsten vier Jahre gut überstehen, egal wie's ausgeht.
Also nie war eine Karton heißer, also
ja, die, wenn sie fallen gelassen wird, also klar, die müssen sich alle in in Sicherheit bringen und die sehen halt jetzt die Fälle davonschwimmen und jetzt muss halt so schnell wie möglich der Turner geschafft werden, damit sie danach noch eine Zukunft haben.
Eiertanz.
Ich denke eigentlich, dass das skandalöse ist aber, und das war ja tatsächlich
vollständig zu erwarten, also tatsächlich ist ja die die der Ablauf dessen, was hier passiert, ist ziemlich genau das, was was relativ viele vorhergesagt haben. Unter anderem auch ähm Bernie Sanders. Du hast die Situation, dass du in mehreren US
Staaten noch auf die ähm,
auf die Briefwahl wartest, du hast die Situation, dass diese Briefwahl tendenziell eher demokratisch ist, sodass frühe Vorsprünge,
äh US-Präsidenten Donald Trump schwinden je länger ausgezählt ist, je länger ausgezählt wird, weshalb er sich
versucht hat, damit ist er eigentlich relativ kläglich gescheitert, sich frühzeitig zum Sieger der Wahl zu erklären in der Wahlnacht, um zu sagen, wir wir rufen jetzt den Supreme Court an, damit aufgehört wird, aus weiter auszuzählen,
Ähm wer hat dann äh das war
war das gestern, ja, da ist er nochmal irgendwie äh vor die Presse getreten, hat dann nochmal irgendwie erzählt, dass äh dass hier ja gerade der absolute Skandal stattfindet und.
In die Wahl gestohlen wird und.
Fordert jetzt in einigen Bundesstaaten, dass die sofortige Beendigung der Auszählung und den anderen Bundesstaaten, dass sie unbedingt weiterzählen müssen. Also es ist ein.
Kläglicher äh kläglicher durchschaubarer Versuch, den er aber mit mit einer Tirade an Vorwürfen
gegen ungefähr jede Person, die da irgendwie an der Auszählung dieser Wahl beteiligt ist, in Staaten, die nicht an ihn gegangen sind und damit ein.
Katastrophaler Flurschaden an der Demokratie. Und das war abzusehen, also es war klar, der geht nicht ohne ähm möglichst viel noch mit kaputt zu machen und das ist eine ähm.
Es ist ein.
Ich kann es nicht anders bezeichnen als einen absoluten Alptraum, ja. Und ich habe mir irgendwie heute so gedacht, was gibt es eigentlich, was ähnlich schlimm ist,
Vier Jahre Donald Trump und um es loszuwerden, weißt du, du musst jetzt nochmal so richtig,
ins ins Tal der Tränen gehen, ne? Und das Einzige, was mir, was mir, was, was dem ähnelt und das tut mir jetzt leid, das so zu sagen, aber das ist halt Krebs.
Ja, da hast du auch ein langes Leid und um dem Leid ein Ende zu setzen, musst du nochmal in ein besonders schweres Leid gehen. Und so ist Donald Trump.
Wir sind jetzt gerade in Chemo.
Wir sind gerade in Chemo. Ja. Und du weißt nicht, wann die Chemo anschlägt. Und die wird dir als eine ganz fürchterliche Zeit deines Lebens in Erinnerung bleiben und niemand wird sagen, war schön damals.
Also ich leide jetzt nicht mehr als sonst schon, muss ich sagen.
Du, ich glaube, also ich denke, dass gerade äh wirklich vieles noch äh kaputt geht und auch Langzeitschäden nimmt durch diese äh durch diese Vorwürfe und also dass er wirklich.
Ich meine, du kannst eine Wahl verlieren und das ist scheiße und so weiter und du kannst dich dann schlecht verhalten.
Aber wenn du dann die Legitimität dieser Institutionen schädigst ähm und Verschwörungstheorien hervorrufst und so weiter, dann schaffst du halt nochmal einen ganz noch einen viel größeren Schaden als,
ähm als als das, was was du ohnehin schon angerichtet hast, wenn du Donald Trump bist.
Ja, ich glaube auch, also es gibt so diese Vorfreude, die dazu kommt für mich noch, dass er jetzt dann vielleicht wirklich endlich weg ist,
aber was danach kommt ist komplett offen, weil das System Trump, das wird uns bleiben, es ist bewiesen, dass Politiker so an die Macht kommen können und sich sehr stabil an der Macht halten können.
Also ich befürchte so eine Art von Politikerinnen werden wir in Zukunft öfter sehen.
Und ja, also insofern passt die Krebsanalogie vielleicht, weil da ist ja auch so, auch wenn du den Krebs besiegt hast, die ersten fünf Jahre, bleibt dir diese Angst, dass er jederzeit wiederkommen könnte.
Trump metastasiert gerade.
Ja gut, das kann natürlich.
Aber auch alles nach hinten losgehen, weil ich meine, dass er eben jetzt, äh dass man jetzt schon so früh sieht, wie wenig Unterstützung er jetzt auf diesem Weg bekommt, in dem Moment, wo Leute sehen, oho, könnte jetzt aber gleich vorbei sein. Ich würde mich überhaupt nicht wundern,
wenn das sozusagen eine totale Abkehr ist und das könnte natürlich auch dazu führen, dass äh er auch nicht
weiter ähm beschützt wird bei der Verfolgung so seiner ganzen Straftaten. Und dann könnte es nochmal ein richtiges Fest werden. Also,
Entschuldigung, für meinen Optimismus, aber ich kriege eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer bessere Laune.
Das kommt, das kommt ein bisschen darauf an, ob das Ding nachher, was weiß ich, mit äh zweihundertsiebzig Wahlpersonen für äh beiden oder was weiß ich, dreihundertsechs Wahlpersonen für beiden endet, wie bereit,
die Republikaner sind sich von ihrem von ihrem Tumor da los zu machen oder nicht.
Dann zuletzt auch noch die Frage, so mit der Special Election in Georgia wird er wahrscheinlich dann erst entschieden, welche Mehrheiten es im Senat gibt,
Und wenn die Republikaner es schaffen, eine der Kammern im Parlament für sich zu behalten
dann werden das auch keine leichten vier Jahre Joe Biden und zumindest mal alle Reformen, die dieses System in den USA demokratischer machen, kannst du dann vergessen, weil die kriegst du nie durch den Sinn ab.
Das ist richtig, aber auch da sieht's grade mal gar nicht so schlecht aus, weil halt zwei Senatssitze in Georgia auch wieder ähm die Republikaner liegen zwar vorne, aber haben nicht fünfzig Prozent, das heißt, es wird eine Stichwahl geben und.
Dann.
Ja, könnte könnte es sein, dass das äh das Momentum dann doch äh auf Seiten der Demokraten ist. Das wird sich natürlich alles erst zeigen, aber noch ist nicht alles äh verloren.
Ist gut. Ich glaube, Team ist unser dedizierter Optimist für dieses.
Entschuldigung, ich bin immer optimistisch. Das ist äh.
Einzige, der keine Flasche Schampus zu Hause stehen hat, was ist das denn für ein Optimist? Bist du kein Optimist?
Ciao.
Haben sich übrigens sehr viele Leute auch auf Twitter nach erkundigt, ne, wie lange ich denn wie lange der äh Schampus haltbar ist und so.
Macht euch keine Sorgen, das Zeug, das Teufelszeug ist geduldig, das wird schon.
Das wird schon. Ich bleibe da auch optimistisch, aber ich sage das wird ein ein äh Sieg zweiter Klasse werden maximal.
Ja
Also ich meine, man wundert sich natürlich, warum überhaupt siebzig Millionen Leute überhaupt noch in der Lage sind, für diesen Typen zu stimmen. Das ist einfach haben wir uns jetzt schon die ganze Zeit gefragt, das werden wir uns auch weiterhin fragen. Es ist äh absurd.
Zumal ja auch die USA ein
Wahlmobilisierung hat, wo man ja gedacht hätte, okay, jetzt kommen jetzt die ganzen äh aufrechten und Unterdrückten und machen den Unterschied und das
tun sie ja im Prinzip auch. Ich meine, wir haben ja eine Mehrheit. So, das ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt ist an zwanzigtausend Stimmen insgesamt hängt, sondern eben nur durch dieses Wahlsystem hängt es äh an solchen Zahlen.
Und gut, für so ein geteiltes Land in jeder Hinsicht geteiltes Land
sind dann die paar Millionen schon mal ein relativ deutliches Ergebnis. Käme bis jetzt nur auf die an, würde niemand sagen, dass das jetzt irgendwie ein knapper Sieg ist,
Es ist halt nur wegen des Wahlsystems ein knapper Sieg.
Ja, wobei die, also ich denke da auch immer so an die ganzen Überlegungen, die in anderen Staaten hier dranhängen. Also ob
man jetzt vielleicht wirklich anfangt, sich selber um die Verteidigung ähm zum Beispiel von Europa,
kümmern, weil das mit der Schirmherrschaft von den USA, darauf kann man sich einfach nicht verlassen. Also ich glaube, solche Überlegungen
werden wir zu, also die werden jetzt durch eine beiden Präsidentschaft trotzdem weitergeführt. Ähm also die USA ist stabiler Partner.
Das hat Trump, glaube ich, langfristig zerstört und das Vertrauen kriegen die USA auch nicht mehr so schnell zurück.
Sicherlich nicht. Nee, da muss äh einiges an Abbiege geleistet werden und Versicherungen ähm aufgemacht werden,
aber das halte ich auch nicht für ausgeschlossen, dass sie diesen Weg jetzt auch gehen wollen, gerade weil sie wissen, wie viel Porzellan zertrümmert ist, das könnte sich auch ganz positiv äh auswirken, gerade weil eben einfach ihre Position schwach geworden ist.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lange hier jetzt noch irgendwie diskutiert wird und geklagt wird und so, ich habe äh damals, ich habe noch in sehr guter Erinnerung, weil das war tatsächlich die Zeit, wo ich in den USA war, ähm,
die den Wahlkampf Bushcorr, da hat's noch relativ lange gedauert, wie die sich gezankt haben, um ihre.
Ähm um die Auszählung der Stimmen und so weiter. Ich hoffe, dass es nicht so so knapp wird am Ende, aber ähm ich glaube, in Michigan und Wisconsin hat,
Trump ja jetzt schon eingereicht seine komischen Klagen und Beschwerden. Mal schauen, wo er das noch alles macht.
Wollt ihr nicht weit mitkommen, denke ich mal. Also, wenn's wenn's rechnerisch jetzt nach der Stimmenauszählung äh für Beiden,
ausgeht, dann dann wird's auch dabei bleiben. Da habe ich mir eigentlich relativ sicher. Das wird das zwar alles vielleicht noch ein bisschen in die Länge ziehen, aber am Ende substanziell nicht viel ändern. Es könnte eher noch dazu beitragen, dass sie eben den Senat auch noch verlieren.
Das verändert hat schön. Aber es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere gute Nachrichten. Unter anderem, dass äh Steve Bennon jetzt irgendwie von YouTube äh und Spotify geflogen ist. Ah nee, Spotify ist er, glaube ich, noch, ne? Was haben sie.
Glaube, der ist nur von Twitter geflogen, oder?
YouTube auch.
Von YouTube auch?
Hm und diesen.
Okay. Also er hat.
Hat ja, der hat ja so ein ganz furchtbaren Kanal äh aufgemacht schon vor längerer Zeit. Wie hieß das Ding? Hast du den Namen gerade mal parat?
Oder?
Japandemic war, also das ist sozusagen also.
Warroom Pandamic.
Das ist also da habe ich mal irgendwie zwei, drei Minuten reingehört, der also,
Das ist schlimm. Das, also das ist Trump ist ist dagegen wirklich ein Kasperletheater. Aber dieser Bennon, das ist einfach äh gnadenlos und jetzt hat er's halt auch völlig übertrieben, indem er irgendwie zur Enthauptung von.
Aufgerufen hat und da ist dann einigen Leuten so ein bisschen der Kragen geplatzt, was jetzt eben zur äh Kanäle äh seiner ja seiner seiner Outlets geführt hat auf den Plattformen.
Also genau und den FBI die sollen also geköpft werden und ihre Köpfe irgendwie aufn
auf ähm Stäben und dann sollen die ausgestellt werden im Weißen Haus als Warnung für alle,
Angestellten, dass man entweder hier mitmacht oder geköpft wird. Ja, okay, das äh konnte dann, da gab's dann irgendwo eine Community-Richtlinie, der das nicht mehr entspricht. Das.
Haben sie doch noch eine gefunden.
Der konnte der jetzt auch nicht mehr mitrechnen, ne.
Ja, entspricht denn das noch ihren richtigen? Ja, also äh ich glaube also.
Raschel, raschel, äh warten sie mal. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das jeden Verstoß gegen.
Das ist ab wann gilt das? Ja, also wie ich das sehe ab sofort.
Unverzüglich.
Aber das ist doch schön, dass es Trumps Account, wenn er nimmer Präsident ist, darf dann auch richtig moderiert werden. Das wird schön.
Oh ja, das wär da bin ich mal gespannt, auf der dann Seite so irgendwie so ein Jack, ihm gegenüber sitzt und sagt so, ja, du hast alle Twitter-Privilegien verloren und äh wir sperren dich jetzt übrigens wegen eines Tweets von,
zweitausendsechzehn.
Werden die auch machen, glaube ich. Also sie haben schon angekündigt, dass.
Habe ich auch so ein bisschen drüber spekuliert, ne? Wenn du dir jetzt mal anschaust, also was machen US-Präsidenten,
im Ruhestand, ne. Also die gehen dann erstmal, ziehen die sich ein bisschen zurück, dann dann kriegst du so irgendwelche Urlaubsbilder, ne. Ähm
keine Ahnung, fahren sie mal bitte irgendwo machen sie mit einem Boot Urlaub von von Jeffrey oder sowas, ne? Und dann ähm äh
keine Ahnung, dann dann gründen sie eine Stiftung oder haben ja schon eine Stiftung und für die Stiftung fahren sie da ein bisschen rum, dann kassieren sie irgendwie ähm,
großzügige Vortragshonorare und halten sich so ein bisschen aus der Politik raus, ja? Ähm.
Obama hat jetzt damit äh ein bisschen gebrochen, als er sich dann jetzt hier zum Ende des Wahlkampfes dann auch mal äh grob seine Gedanken geäußert hat zu zu Donald Trump.
Ähm die Frage ist, was macht ein Trump? Weil,
Also die Fresse halten wir denn nicht. Und andererseits ist das ja aber auch, also ich meine, man muss ja ganz ehrlich sagen, Trump ist ja kein politischer Mensch. Es ist ja jetzt nicht so denkbar, dass sagen wir mal in zwei Jahren ähm die.
Präsidentin oder der Präsident der USA in irgendeiner, in irgendeinem neuen, neuartigen Konflikt steht, ja, der oder einer Abwägung
Ist zu beurteilen gibt. Es gibt eine inhaltliche politische Debatte und dann schaltet Fox News Donald Trump dazu und der sagt,
Ich halte in der Frage der Gesundheitsversorgung es für sinnvoller ähm das Existenzrecht, Palästinas anzuerkennen und ähm außerdem hier eine Koalition mit,
ähm.
Kim Jong-un einzugehen und als Begründung dafür nenne ich die äh Interessen von Benjamin Netanjahu und wir müssen hier aufpassen oder sowas, ne? Der wird ja äh sowas wird der ja nicht machen. Der wird dann einfach nur immer sagen,
Wenn wenn ich wiedergewählt worden wäre, wenn wenn mir die Wahl nicht gestohlen wäre, hätten wir das Problem nicht. Oder sowas, ne?
Also ich frage, ich frage mich auch wirklich, wie will der im das muss ja eine ganz ähm ganz verbitterte arme Kröte werden in äh im im Ruhestand.
Ja, da wird genug Probleme äh haben irgendwie äh seine Kredite zurückzuzahlen. Das könnte ja erstmal das Problem werden. Deutsche Bank will jetzt auch die Kohle haben.
Doch dafür verantwortlich, wieso gibt die Deutsche Bank einfach nicht mal irgendwie so einen Cut und.
Oh, hat sie ja jetzt,
sie haben ja sie haben sich jetzt schon äh beklagt und ähm sie meinten auch, sie würden wahrscheinlich diese Schulden nicht weiterverkauft bekommen, also es würde wohl keiner haben, den Stress.
Aber sie hätten halt bisher nur Zinszahlungen gesehen, aber noch überhaupt gar keine Rückzahlungen. Und da sind so, was weiß ich, dreihundert Millionen Euro oder sowas in der Größenordnung im Raum,
Also, ich denke, dem wird's schon an Kragen gehen. Also, der hat einfach so viel Kohle überall hängen und der besitzt halt eigentlich auch keine. Und die Hotels verdienen auch nichts.
Die Frage ist einfach, wem nützt er noch? Also welche Interessen können Trump,
jetzt noch über die Präsidentschaft hinaus am Leben und im öffentlichen Spotlight halten
und funktioniert er medial als Ex-Präsident so wie er als Kandidaten als Präsident funktioniert hat. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass Fox ihn weglegen wird, dass das republikanische Establishment versucht, sich von ihm zu lösen. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob sie das schaffen
und wenn ihm dann die Medien wegbrechen, ähm dann, ich meine, der kann immer noch seine halten
Das wird auch spannend, ob dann noch Leute kommen und wie radikale oder militant es dort zugehen wird, aber eigentlich das.
Das kriegt er aber nicht finanziert.
Ja. Eben aber ich meine, vielleicht äh hat da Russland noch ein Interesse dran, den zu.
Glaube ich nicht. Wie gesagt, das der wird fallen gelassen werden und äh wird einen verbitterten Tod sterben.
Also wenn der jetzt abgewählt wird, dann ist der auch weg. Und dann wird er bei irgend so ein anderer Heini, wird schon irgendwie äh kommen, aber die wollen jetzt natürlich alle kalif statt des Kalifen werden,
Das ist jetzt eigentlich das interessante Rennen. Also wer holt die Kohlen da irgendwie aus dem Feuer für die Republikaner in der Zukunft und ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt nochmal sich trauen auf Trump zu setzen?
Äh ich ich das würde ich nicht sagen, ich glaube zumindest der Name Trump wird uns in der amerikanischen Politik erhalten bleiben. Er hat ja leider viele Kinder.
Na, na ja gut, damit ist natürlich zu rechnen, dass jetzt irgendwie Ivanca äh irgendwie äh ankommt, aber.
Oh Mann, ey, Ivan hat Trump zwanzig vierundzwanzig, das wird's, Leute. Okay, sollen wir mal uns äh unserem Kernthemengebiet wieder äh widmen?
Würde ich einmal ein kleines, kurzes Announcement in eigener Sache machen. Wir haben gestern Abend den,
der Remote Experience,
gelauncht. Also, ihr wisst ja, es wird dieses Jahr keinen CCC-Kongress geben. Es gibt aber zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr ein Online-Event, mit dem wir,
die Lehre in euren Herzen füllen möchten.
Bei diesem äh dieses Event wird primär auf euren Bildschirmen stattfinden und in euren Webcams, aber ähm gibt ja sicherlich auch Leute, denen,
wahrscheinlich nicht so liegt unbedingt.
Zu Hause in ihrem Wohnzimmer oder Büro einen Vortrag zu halten, deswegen wird es sogenannte Chaos-Studios geben in verschiedenen Städten, also ja im Prinzip Aufzeichnungsstudios mit einer Bühne.
Wo ihr die Vorträge
Aufzeichnung aufzeichnen oder livestreamen könnt. Diese Chaostudies werden teilweise auch ihre eigenen Community-Bühnen unterhalten. Ähm
also oder quasi ihre eigenen Kanäle bei der bei der RC drei, das ist dann so ein bisschen wie was man auch schon sonst kennt, ne? Oyo zum Beispiel Orbit ähm,
hat ja auch ein eigenes Bühnenprogramm beim Kongress, so wird es eben auch bei der RC drei sein. Und bei diesem CFP, wenn ihr dort einreicht, gehen die Einreichungen ähm an alle, die sie haben wollen. Das heißt, auch die Community-Bühnen können darauf zugreifen und euch dann in das,
Programm aufnehmen in in ihr Programm aufnehmen,
Also ist gerade gelauncht, die Einreichungsfrist ist der zwanzigste November, ja, also grade mal vierzehn Tage bleiben euch, es wäre also,
wenn ihr euch da jetzt drüber Gedanken macht, die Benachrichtigung kommt dann am dreißigsten November, wie gesagt, ihr könnt die Vorträge live oder vor aufgezeichnet zu Hause oder in einem Chaosstudio halten und wie das dann genau passiert, erklärt die Aufnahme.
Erklärt die Aufnahmeleitung dann mit euch, wenn ihr die Benachrichtigung über die Annahme eurer Einreichung bekommt
Ähm den Link zum CFP Ulm und den zum Einreichungsformular findet ihr bei uns in den ansonsten findet ihr auf Events Punkt CC Punkt DE sowieso alle Informationen zu diesem und zukünftigen,
Events und ja, wir freuen uns auf hochkarätige Einreichungen für diesen,
Anlass.
Genau, dann gab's noch äh Feedback, Diverses. Äh unter anderem haben wir äh ein bisschen Quatsch
erzählt ich ärgere mich so ein bisschen, weil es mir in dem Moment auch noch durch den Kopf gegangen ist, aber ich glaube, wir haben's dann vergessen zu sagen, deswegen die Korrektur von außen. Wir haben uns ja zu dem Lockdown in Deutschland oder Lockdown light oder wie auch immer man das jetzt nennen soll
geäußert und gesagt, dass jetzt Ausgleichszahlungen stattfinden für geschlossene Betriebe, also,
Kneipenrestaurants, Kulturbetriebe et cetera und gesagt, äh hier wird eine Erstattung des Vor äh des des Monats davor,
äh also in der Höhe äh gezahlt, ähm ist natürlich Unsinn, es geht um den Vorjahresmonat, also.
In diesem November wird quasi November neunzehn als Vergleichsmonat angelegt und das.
Die Größenordnung. Alles andere wäre auch also erstens wäre es eine schlechte Entscheidung und zweitens wäre es auch Unsinn, weil diese Zahlen ja quasi ähm dem Finanzamt noch gar nicht vorliegen.
Ich bin auch ein bisschen verwundert, dass ich das so gesagt habe, weil ich weiß auch, dass es so war. Ich muss mich da irgendwie verquatscht haben, wie dem auch sei, daraufhin haben.
Ja, ich glaube auch, dass wir so ein bisschen durcheinander gebracht oder nicht ausreichend erläutert.
Darauf haben uns äh Sam und Alina hingewiesen und äh Martino ergänzte dann noch, wenn man Vermieter zum Beispiel von Gaststätten und sonstigen,
an den Kosten beteiligen würde, müsste man übrigens auch keine fünfundsiebzig Prozent Entschädigung zahlen. Gaststätten bräuchten weniger Geld zum Überleben. Die Angestellten könnten auf größere Teile ihres äh Einkommens verzichten.
Mieten, müssen ja nicht gleich ganz auf null gesenkt werden, nur damit allen klar ist.
Dass man das Geld eben nicht wirklich, dass das Geld eben nicht wirklich in die Restaurants fliegt, fließt, ne. Ähm also,
bei den, bei vielen dieser Entschädigungs- oder Zwischensummen ist es ja so, dass die wenn man mal ganz ehrlich sagt,
dass diese Einrichtung dann nur noch als Geldboten noch missbraucht werden, ja? Und dann eben Geld bekommen, was sie dann eben an ihre Vermieter geben dürfen. Insofern halte ich an der äh Idee fest, dass es,
dass diese Krise bei den Vermieterinnen und Vermietern ankommen muss und die einzige These,
die dagegen spricht, ist dass dann die Leute sagen, ja dann können die aber ihre Zinsen und ihre Raten auf die Kredite nicht mehr zahlen. Erstens ist das tatsächlich bei den, bei vielen
Gewerbevermieterin nicht so, dass die das Ding noch irgendwie großartig finanziert haben. Zweitens habe ich schon Anfang,
Anfang dieser Pandemie oder dieser Krisensituation gefordert, diese gesamte, das nicht nur auf Vermieter auszuweiten, sondern eben auch auf Kapitalerträge. Insofern.
Dass es genauso,
in dem gleichen Maße wie man vielleicht Mietzahlungen von Mietzahlungen befreit, genauso die ähm Kredite,
und Zinsen von denen befreien müsste und halt sagt, es ist nunmal leider eine Krise und diese Krise kommt nun auch beim Kapital an und nicht nur.
Allem anderen. Also mein Vorschlag wäre diese Krise insbesondere bei Kapitalerträgen ankommen.
Dann wurden wir noch von Pascal korrigiert oder nicht korrigiert, ergänzt, weil ich gesagt habe, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der Snowden ähm fünf Millionen US-Dollar mit seinem Buch verkauft
äh eingenommen hat. Da hat äh Pascal eine längere äh Entgegnung geschrieben, eine längere Erläuterung. Ich nehme mal nur ein Teil davon. Erstens
Natürlich ziehen die Verlage massiv vor Kosten ab, aber circa acht bis fünfzehn Prozent, je verkauftes Exemplar gehen
wenn man's nicht noch besser aushandelt eben an den Autor, die gebundene Ausgabe von Permanent Record kostet brutto circa zwanzig Euro, Taschenbuch zehn Euro, absoluter Bestseller, international
Ähm hat zwar keine Verkaufszahlen gefunden, aber wenn man
den weltweiten Vertrieb des Buches annimmt, dann sind fünf Millionen Euro sehr realistisch geschätzt. Äh Pascal sagt, da wäre wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr drin, weil man vermuten kann, dass es Snowden vielleicht besser verhandelt hat.
Dann sagt er noch,
noch etwas zur Durchsetzung von Ansprüchen gegen natürliche Personen, die Rechtssysteme lassen in der Regel zu, Zahlungsansprüche einer Person an den Gläubiger,
überzuleiten. In Deutschland könnte zum Beispiel die Finanzverwaltung oder auch jeder andere Gläubiger Tanthemenansprüche eines Autors im Wege eines Pfändungs,
und Überweisungsbeschlusses an sich überführen. Man muss als Gläubiger also nicht warten, bis der Schuldner von einem dritten Geld erhält, Voraussetzung ist natürlich ein gerichtlicher Titel,
oder bei der Finanzverwaltung ein entsprechender Bescheid. Das wird in den USA wohl nicht anders sein, sagt äh Pascal.
Dann äh hatte ich ja äh äh mich erfreut an diesem YouTube-Video über das Obsttaxi.
Da weist uns mag der Lokomotivführer hin, dass wenn man sich dieses Video anschaut, einem direkt eine Dokumentation von Steuerung F ähm.
Empfohlen wird, die für viele Videos von Joko und Klaas ähm,
äh äh nachweist, dass die in Wirklichkeit gestellt wurden. Das heißt, die haben äh,
viele ihrer Aktionen gefaket und es steht eben auch zu vermuten, dass diese Obsttaxi-Nummer ähm ebenfalls gefaked ist.
Ähm hat der YouTube Algorithmus mal eine sinnvolle Empfehlung gemacht. Ähm.
Nichtsdestotrotz fand ich das Video witzig, aber ist natürlich wichtig, zu sagen, ist ein Fake. Oder ist, es steht zu vermuten, dass es ein Fake ist.
Ziemlich naheliegend sogar, wenn man sich dieses Video anschaut. Also ich war mit diesem äh Gesamtwerk dieser Leute noch nicht so richtig vertraut und äh na ja, das ist Albaner Kram.
Ich sage so oft, aber ähm.
Dann haben wir äh äh haben wir über die Ratspräsidentschaft Deutschlands gesprochen und dass die Bundesregierung,
hier sich eben anstrengen und wie zu erwarten war, musste Simon mich korrigieren und schreibt Linus, Rat der Europäischen Union, nicht Europarat. Falsche internationale Organisation und ebenfalls nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Europäischen Rat.
Und weil es sonst noch alles.
Bewusst schwierig gemacht.
Äh und und weil es sonst noch alles viel zu verständlich wäre, ist die rotierende Ratspräsidentschaft eigentlich keine Präsidentschaft, sondern der Vorsitz des Ratzes der Europäischen Union. Ein Präsident hat nur der Europäische Rat,
Alles ganz einfach zu merken, wenn man das jedes Mal vorher nochmal schnell in der Wikipedia nachschlägt. Ja, hast du recht.
Es tut mir leid, äh ich krieg's äh.
Hätte ich hätte ich eigentlich merken müssen, aber habe ich äh in dem Moment.
Kann das, ich nicht. Ja.
Ja ja.
So und dann gab es noch äh ähm Sprachkritik von Tanja.
Tanja kommentiert zur letzten Sendung. Spätestens, wenn Terroristen von Linus als Terroristinnen bezeichnet werden, um der Sache der Gleichberechtigung von Frauen einen Dienst zu erweisen, wird deutlich,
dass in so einer trotzigen Brechstangen Sprachpolitik der Wurm drin ist. Im Ergebnis werden außerhalb der linken Blase emanzimatorische Bemühungen lächerlich gemacht,
und Delegitimiert, aber links sein bedeutet ja traditionell leider eher sich richtig zu fühlen, als wirklich etwas zu verändern.
Liebe Tanja.
Moment, hast du von Terroristen, von Terroristinnen oder Terroristinnen gesprochen?
Ich habe Terroristinnen gesagt, ich benutze ja, wann immer es mir gelingt, das generische Femininum. Ich würde Tanja jetzt gerne kurz entgegnen. Liebe Tanja,
Ulrike Meinhoff, Gudrun Enzlin, Susanne Albrecht, Monika Helbrich, Birgit Hohgefeld, Verena Becker,
Brigitte Astung, Ingeborg Barts, Brigitte Mohnhaupt, Silke Mayerwitt, Irmgard Möller, Waltraud Book, Irene Görgens, Eva Haule, Hanna Krabbe,
Christine Kubi, Ingrid Schubert, Adelheid Schulz, Angelika Spey, Sigrid, Sternebeck, Inge Feed, Brigitte Kuhlmann, ähm,
Es liegt mir fern, dass Wirken dieser Genossinnen nicht zu würdigen, wenn ich von Terroristinnen spreche und ansonsten gibt's auch noch Beate Zschäpe, die ich nicht würdige
und auch der IS sucht zudem Frauen.
Weil es eben auch unter den Männern Unmengen an Jungfrauen gibt, die im Himmel noch verteilt werden müssen. Insofern, es gibt Terroristinnen und insofern,
denke ich, es ist völlig in Ordnung. Deren ähm Wirken dann hier auch anzuerkennen.
Bin so emanzipatorisch.
Alles hat irgendwas hat der.
Andreas Barder gehabt. Okay, dann kommen wir ähm zu noch zu der parlamentarischen Beteiligung an den Corona-Maßnahmen. Da hatte ich.
Glaube ich eher, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das unbedingt so.
Auch gesagt habe, dass ich das ähnlich finde, aber ähm wie dem auch sei, so hat es äh Jan empfunden und sagt, ich fand Linus Kritik an der Nichtbeteiligung des Parlaments nicht ganz zu Ende gedacht.
Erstens, kann der Bundestag und können die Landesparlamente ihre Tagesordnung selbst bestimmen. Die Debatte über die Schutzmaßnahmen hätte
also schon längst gelaufen sein können. Zweitens, besteht jedenfalls im Bundestag das Recht des Parlaments Vertreterinnen der Bundesregierung jederzeit zur Anwesenheit im Plenum zu verpflichten
zum Beispiel Vergleiche Artikel dreiundvierzig Grundgesetz. Wo sind die kleinen und großen Anfragen? Wo sind die Fragen an die Bundesregierung in der Sitzungswoche
Es ist doch gerade eine der wichtigen Aufgaben der Parlamente, die jeweilige Regierung zu kontrollieren, dem sollten sie dann aber auch nachkommen. Und drittens,
liegt noch die Rechtsgrundlage der Corona-Verordnungen der Länder.
Bundesinfektionsschutzgesetz. Mir ist jedenfalls keine Gesetzesinitiative in der Bundes- und Länderlegisative bekannt.
Die hier eine Zustimmung des Bundestages oder der Länderparlamente erfordert. Im Gegenteil, meines Erachtens sind die Verordnungsbefugnisse durch die letzte Änderung des Infektionsschutzgesetzes durch den Bundesgesetzgeber
noch einmal erweitert worden. Sich jetzt also hinzustellen und die mangelnde Beteiligung der Parlamente zu beklagen finde ich ein bisschen unredlich.
Und es wundert mich dann doch, dass Linus dieses Lied mitsingt,
kann ja gar nicht so gut singen, aber äh tatsächlich finde ich den Hinweis sehr wichtig und es ist ja tatsächlich so, dass.
Eine große Klage aus dem Parlamenten kam an diesen Verordnungen nicht beteiligt worden zu sein. Und ich denke, Jan hat hier sehr gut,
aufgelistet, was welche Möglichkeiten die Parlamente sowohl auf Landes und Bundesebene gehabt hätten sich hier,
einzubringen und ähm insofern
kann ich der Argumentation hier sehr gut folgen eben zu sagen ist es klar sich als sich als Gauland dann am Ende dahinzusetzen und zu sagen äh hier die Regierung und so Merkel-Diktatur und da äh
Danke, Jan für die Korrektur oder für die das Geraderücken äh dieses Eindrucks.
Gut, ähm damit würde ich sagen, kommen wir aus dem Feedback-Teil dann endlich raus und äh kommen damit zum Arschloch.
Ja, das ist ein Wiener Begriff und ähm der, der ist in dieser Woche sehr wichtig geworden. Es ist was passiert.
Internationaler Begriff Thomas.
Diese Aussprache das Arschloch oder das Asol, kannst du sagen, ist international, aber das Wiener Arschloch, ich glaube, das hat schon, da haben wir Lokalpatrimus.
Das würde ich doch auch meinen.
Ähm also es ist ein Terroranschlag. In Wien passiert am Montag dieser Woche,
ähm und darüber wollen wir kurz sprechen
also zuerst vielleicht ganz kurz, was ist passiert? Am Montag, den zweiten November, kurz vor zwanzig Uhr ähm
hat ein zwanzig Jähriger angefangen in der Wiener Innenstadt um sich zu schießen und zwar genau in der Seitenstädtergasse. Das ist ähm direkt in der Nähe ähm der größten jüdischen Synagoge
in Wien und ähm ja diese äh Person hat dann einen Amoklauf oder oder Terrorlauf durch die innere Stadt äh vollzogen.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ähm war, dass hier viele Leute unterwegs äh vielleicht so als Kontext ab Dienstag dieser Woche ähm
gibt es äh Lockdown in Österreich, also die gesamte Gastronomie ist geschlossen äh wegen der Coronazahlen
ähm geht das Land irgendwie so in verfrühten Winterschlaf und das war sozusagen die letzte legale Möglichkeit, nochmal was trinken zu gehen, einen Kaffee trinken zu gehen, sich mit Freunden zu treffen oder überhaupt ein Restaurant zu besuchen,
noch dazu war das ein für den November sehr warmer Tag. Insofern war da wirklich viel los.
Die Person hat also insgesamt sind vier Menschen zu Tode gekommen, circa zweiundzwanzig Verletzte,
darunter übrigens auch eine deutsche Studentin, die ähm Kunst in,
In Wien studiert und generiert hat im ersten Bezirk. Circa neun Minuten nach Auslösen des Terrorans um zwanzig Uhr äh ist der Attentäter von der Polizei erschossen worden.
Und das ist insgesamt das erste terroristische Attentat in Wien seit den achtziger Jahren, also das letzte war neunzehneinundachtzig,
perfide Weise genau in der selben Seitenstädtergasse, weil eben in der Seitenstädtergasse vier dieser jüdische Tempel diese Synagoge ist.
Inzwischen hat auch der IS den Anschlag für sich reklamiert und das ist auch ein Video aufgetaut wo sich der Täter zum IS ähm bekannt hat.
Also das ist so ungefähr, was was passiert ist. Was ich aber auch eben sehr bemerkenswert finde, ist die Reaktion.
Auf dieses Ereignis gezeigt hat.
Also natürlich wurde sofort Alarm ausgegeben irgendwie Prozess hat mein Handy geleitet von der ganzen Breaking News und danach von allen Leuten, die sich ähm erkundigt haben, ob man eh,
safe ist. Ähm die Innenstadt wurde großflächig abgesperrt. Ähm also es kam wirklich enorm viel Polizei,
an diesen Ort versammelt, Hubschrauber, Sondereinheiten später auch das Militär, was den Objektschutz übernommen hat.
Und ähm,
die Leute, die noch in der Innenstadt waren, mussten dort auch noch eine Zeit lang verharren, also bis drei Uhr früh oder noch äh später, weil man sich nicht sicher war, ob es nur einen Täter gegeben hat oder mehrere. Deswegen haben sie sozusagen die komplette Innenstadt
mal ähm durchpflügt, um zu schauen, ob sie diese Person auch finden. Ähm es hat sich dann aber später herausgestellt, dass es eben wirklich nur diesen einen Täter gab
man hat einfach Wegzeitprotokolle gemacht und konnte das dann mit Sicherheit sagen, obwohl Sex Tatorte gab. Das waren einfach die Orte, wo er gesehen wurde.
Ähm der Täter ist ähm geboren in Österreich, in Mödlingen, hat der Ellabbrecher Doppelstaatsbürgerschaft Österreichisch Nord, Mazedonisch.
Was ist HTL?
Höhere technische Lehranstalt, das ist so die technischen Ausbildungsberufe, ich hab so was auch gemacht und und damit dreizehn Programmieren gelernt, das kannst du auch lernen, um weiß nicht, Bautechnik zu lernen oder Elektronik, das sind so,
eigentlich die die Schulen, die die Abitur und eine Berufsausbildung auf einmal geben.
Ist so ein Vorort von Wien, ne?
Das ist äh sehr nah an Wien, größte HTL, glaube ich, die es in Österreich gibt. Und da,
Ist er zur Schule gegangen, aber hat eben keinen Abschluss gemacht. Ähm insgesamt, also was man weiß, ist ähm diese Person hat ähm.
Schon versucht sich dem IS anzuschließen. Ähm ist in äh der Türkei aufgehalten worden, eben beim Versuch des Grenzübertritts äh nach Syrien
wurde dann später zurück überstellt ähm nach Österreich.
Und ähm dort dann eben auch äh eigentlich wegen Mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen Organisation und einer terroristischen Vereinigung ähm verurteilt,
Ähm aber.
Was eben an dieser Tat nach noch spannend ist, also ähm es ist ja haben dann sie haben irrsinnig schnell,
Hausdurchsuchungen, achtzehn Hausdurchsuchungen durchgeführt, vierzehn Verhaftungen. Ähm der Großteil von den Leuten ist äh,
Teenager oder oder Tweeneiter, also zwischen sechzehn und und in ihren zwanzigern. Ähm.
Das jüngste Opfer ist ein ein Albaner. Ähm wir haben dann aber auch ähm,
drei Jungs, die vor Ort geholfen haben, ähm ich glaube, alle drei mit äh türkischen Hintergrund, die inzwischen auch in den Medien sehr gefeiert wurden.
Und äh das hat auch so ein bissel dazu geführt, dass jetzt wenig,
rassistische Reaktion auf diesen dieser Tat ist. Also auch unser Innenminister, der wirklich kein sonderlicher Freund der Freiheit ist, ähm,
hat in seiner ersten Reaktion dazu aufgerufen, sich jetzt nicht auseinanderdividieren zu lassen, äh diesen Anschlag nicht für äh.
Billigen Angriff gegen den Islam oder Muslima zu verwenden. Also da hat Österreich erstaunlich erwachsen reagiert aus meiner Sicht.
Ähm,
Und ja, weswegen wir vorher vom Arschloch geredet haben, das war in einem der Videos, die es von der Tat gibt, die erste Reaktion von einem der Anrainer, der dem Attentäter aus dem Fenster ähm zugeschrien hat, schleicht die du Arschloch,
und das ist so ein bissel auch der Slogan geworden mit dem Wien Versuch, dieses ganze Ereignis zu verarbeiten und damit umzugehen. Also,
ähm äh ist das äh ist der Hashtag geworden, den die die Leute auf Social Media verwendet haben, schleicht die du Arschloch. Der Name des Täters,
Ist von ganz vielen Leuten nicht genannt worden, sondern man ist sich einig, man nennt den Typen einfach nur,
Arschloch. Es gibt das dazugehörige Browser-Plug-in, das äh die Nennung des Namens auf Nachrichtenseiten äh durch Arschloch ersetzt. Es gibt T-Shirts, die du kaufen kannst, wo die die Erlöse an.
Karitative Zwecke gehen und.
Ich find's halt irgendwie so so passend, zu viel auch irgendwie. Paris hat seinen, Spanien hat, Großbritannien hat vor London und wir Wiener haben halt schleich dich du Arschloch.
Super. Großartig.
Ist natürlich auch so ein das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie der Migrant oder der, der Muslime, der das getan hat, sondern das ist einfach ein Arschloch. Das ist ein Typ, der viel Scheiße in seinem Leben erlebt hat und der eine unsagbar unmenschliche Tat begangen hat.
Der steht nicht repräsentativ für irgendeine Gruppe und das wird für mich auch so ein bissel ausgedruckt, über diesen, diesen Begriff,
Es gab dann auch noch eine längere Auseinandersetzung, weil die Polizei eigentlich sofort aufgerufen hat,
Videos zu posten von dieser Tat. Es gab eine eigene Seite, wo man uploaden konnte, wenn man irgendwas gefilmt oder fotografiert hat von der Tat,
wiegt Zeitprotokolle erwähnt, die wurden dafür auch gebraucht diese Videos. Und äh innerhalb von achtundvierzig Stunden wurden da zwanzigtausend Videos hochgeladen. Ich glaube mehrere Terabyte.
Ähm und die einzigen zwei Medien, die wirklich die Bilder gebracht haben, waren vor allem.
Vierundzwanzig, also Österreich, äh Tageszeitung und Online-Medium und die Krone,
Wobei die Krone sehr schnell damit aufgehört hat. Und bei Österreich, das ist so wirklich das tiefste Revolverblatt, was es gibt in diesem Land, also
Da ist mit journalistischen Standards,
die muss man da gar nicht erst suchen. Und jetzt gibt's da auch die äh sehr positive Kampagne, dass immer mehr Werbetreibende aufhören, dort Anzeigen zu schalten. Also auch große Einkaufsketten und äh Supermärkte haben aufgehört, dort zu werben.
Noch fehlt ist ein Dementi von Werbung von der Stadt Wien oder vom Bund. Ähm aber es hilft auf jeden Fall schon mal irgendwie, wenn man ja diese Bilder auch nicht zeigt, weil das ist natürlich auch was die Terroristen bezwecken,
äh dieser Aktion, dass wir Angst bekommen, dass terrorischiert wird und dazu muss man nicht Bilder mit Blutlacken sehen. Dazu reicht es, die Tat zu verstehen.
Ähm natürlich gibt's auch politische Konsequenzen.
Ähm das sehe ich aber auch einen kleinen Hoffnungsschimmer. Wir reden nämlich mehr über das Versagen des Geheimdienstes als über neue Überwachung.
Ich habe vorher schon erwähnt, der Täter hat versucht, nach Syrien zu reisen.
Und ähm wurde also dann von der Türkei nach Österreich überführt, wurde auch zu zweiundzwanzig Monaten Haft verurteilt,
Ähm und im Dezember zwanzigneunzehn kann man aber frühzeitig aus der Haft,
und hat aber 'ne Bewährung bekommen, also drei Jahre lang mit starken Auflagen musste sich in die Radikalisierungsprogramm anschließen und theoretisch hätte man ihn auch sehr genau überwachen können in dieser Zeit,
Ähm.
Trotzdem ist da nicht wirklich was passiert, ähm also im Sommer zwanzig zwanzig, also wirklich, das ist noch nicht lange her, äh vor ein paar Monaten im Juli hat er ähm.
Versucht eine Munition zu kaufen in der Slowakei. Was gescheitert ist, weil ähm man dafür einen Waffenschein in der Slowakei braucht,
Die Behörden haben dann Österreich Bescheid gegeben, also da gibt's die Schreiben von der Slowakei, so ha, wir haben ja Überwachungskamera, das sind ähm zwanzigjährige, die gerade irgendwie versuchen, Munition bei uns zu kaufen, äh vielleicht schaut ihr euch die mal an.
Ähm Österreich hat aber drei Monate gebraucht, um überhaupt mal von diesem ähm Überwachungsaufnahmen festzustellen,
wer das eigentlich ist und ähm dann hätte man eigentlich nur,
den der Justizbescheid geben müssen und die werden sofort wieder in Haft gekommen, weil sie ja gegen ihre Bewährungsauflagen verstoßen haben. Aber das ist nicht passiert.
Und da ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie ein Behördenversagen, was man konstatieren muss und ähm.
Äh wäre eigentlich eben das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismusbekämpfung, das BVT zuständig gewesen für diese Art von von Fällen,
ähm aber wie gesagt, der Justiz ist nie Bescheid gegeben worden und scheinbar standen diese Leute auch nicht unter unter Verdacht. Ähm,
Und es gibt im Moment eben so einige Konsequenzen, die wir,
wir sehen oder die, die man eigentlich erwarten müsste, also äh in Deutschland war's ja, glaube ich, auch bei dem bei dem letzten Terroranschlag so, dass äh mal wieder mal Vorratsdatenspeicherung gefordert hat.
Das haben wir in Österreich noch nicht gehört,
Es hätte in dem Fall wäre das ein Ding, was wir auch leicht abschießen können, weil der Täter war ja bekannt, er war vorbestraft, er war unter Bewährung, man muss nicht die gesamte Bevölkerung überwachen, nur um jemanden, der schon auffällig geworden ist, im Blick zu behalten.
Bundestrojaner, also eine eine staatliche Spionage-Software wird schon zum Teil gefordert, aber da.
Glauben wir auch, dass es aufgrund der der Rechtsprechung, wir haben ja im Dezember zwanzig neunzehn Bundestrainer in Österreich ähm als Verfassungswidrig abschaffen können. Ich glaube nicht, dass der so schnell wiederkommt.
Zwei Dinge werden uns bevorstehen. Das eine ist so eine Debatte über ähm Gefähre, also über Sicherheitsverwahrung, ob Leute, die.
Eben vom IS zurückkommen oder die man einfach für Gefährder hält, ob man die präventiv äh wegsperren kann.
Ähm das ist sicherlich eine Debatte, die die Österreich bevorsteht.
Ich glaube auch, dass man die gewinnen kann, weil ähm erstens die Person hätte man wegsperren können, einfach nur, weil sie gegen ihre Bewährungsauflagen verstoßen hat. Dazu brauche ich keine Präventivhaft,
Dieser Begriff des Gefährders, der wurde in Österreich schon zweitausendsiebzehn diskutiert, dass man jetzt einfach.
Ähm Leute, die die Dienste für gefährlich halten, mal einfach so wegsperrt.
Und es gab auch innerhalb der Volkspartei der innerhalb der konservativen keine Mehrheit dafür. Also das hat der Justizminister sich dagegen gestellt und besagte Justizminister ist heute verfassungsrichter Helmut Branstädter.
Also ich glaube, dass dieses ähm Thema, das wird diskutiert werden, aber ich habe eine Hoffnung, dass wir es gewinnen. Was auf jeden Fall kommt, ist eine Reform des BVTs.
Im Moment sind in Österreich Polizei und Geheimdienste in einer Organisation vereint.
Kannst du nochmal kurz sagen, was BVT.
Für Verfassungsschutz und Terrorismus be.
Ähm und äh diese diese Organisation ist halt sowohl Geheimdienst als auch Polizei.
Ähm und äh das vermischt natürlich so ein bisschen den Legalitätsgrundsatz, unter dem die Polizei operiert, dass man.
Nur Dinge, die illegal sind, verfolgt und Verdachten nachgeht und nicht einfach so herumstochert.
Und dem Opportunitätsgrundsatz, dem Geheimdienst erfolgen, dass man mal einfach aufgrund einer abstrakten Risikoeinschätzung.
Ähm sich alle Tschetschenen anschaut oder alle Menschen, die äh, weiß nicht, im Tierschutzbereich aktiv sind, weil man dort Terrorismus vermutet und das wird in Österreich leider jetzt schon vermischt. Das will man trennen,
Damit kommt aber natürlich die Frage, wie kontrolliert man einen Geheimdienst? Wo es keiner wirklich gute Antwort auf der Welt gibt, ähm aber das ist so eines der Themen, die sicherlich auf uns zukommen.
Und,
Natürlich gibt's auch wieder die politischen Debatten, wie die Aufklärung jetzt passieren soll, also das Innenministerium hat schon eingestanden, dass sie eine Untersuchungskommission starten wollen, also die tun gar nicht mal mehr so, als wäre da nicht ein massiver Fehler passiert.
Ähm die Frage ist halt, wie unabhängig und transparent ist diese Aufklärung,
und widmet man sich dann auch wirklich den Problemen, die man da identifizieren konnte. Ähm tja.
Also war eine harte Woche. Zuerst Terroranschlag, dann Lockdown, dann US-Wahl. Ich habe nicht viel geschlafen.
Oh Gott. Also ich muss mal, ich habe
Mir ist schon ein bisschen die Augen gerieben, als ich das Statement von dem Innenminister so gehört habe, dachte ich mir, so was denn was ist denn jetzt hier los? Also
hat sich jetzt gerade irgendwas verändert? Hat das was mit der mit der Regierung zu tun? Irgendwie wacht gerade irgendjemand auf, also
sofort erwartet, dass er die Automatismen greifen und auf alles Fremde und Böse eingeschlagen wird.
Hätte ich auch erwartet. Also es ist wirklich.
Gut, dass die die ÖVP hier gerade ähm nicht nur auf die rechte Seite schielt, sondern gerade wirklich auch so ein bissel die die Mitte im Blick hält und.
Ja, ich ich bin wirklich froh, dass dass man so erwachsen drauf reagiert hat.
Und auch wenn, man weiß nicht, ihr kennt das ja alle, die Medien interviewen Leute auf der Straße, was halten sie vom Anschlag und so? Ja, die Hälfte sagt, wir haben Angst, aber die andere sagt doch, wir sollen uns nicht unterkriegen lassen, also es ist.
Ähm schon ein bissel was Wehrhaftes in dieser Reaktion dabei und ich glaube schon, dass ganz viel damit zu tun hat, ob man den Täter idealisiert und den Namen nennt und so.
Also ähm.
Ich finde einfach, solche Leute sollten ihren Namen nicht in die Geschichtsbücher haben. Man kann das wunderbar schön soziologisch und psychologisch und kriminologisch aufarbeiten, was da passiert ist. Aber ähm idealisieren muss man diese Leute nicht.
Das ist ja so ein neues Mantra, was eigentlich aus Neuseeland äh in die Welt getragen worden ist, nach den Anschlägen, die dort stattgefunden haben, wo ja äh die Ministerpräsidentin das ja sozusagen von Anfang an,
gesagt hat, dass sie diesen Namen niemals erwähnen wird und dass sozusagen so.
Also nicht nur nicht getan hat, sondern auch das, dass sie das nicht tut, so bewusst und offen von Anfang an vertreten hat, dass das ja sozusagen nochmal eine Botschaft,
in sich war, ne? Und ich denke, das ist auch ein Fehler, der oft gemacht worden äh ist, dass man eben diese
Glorifizierung, die ja, glaube ich, diese Einzeltäter äh oder Attentäter und an Terroristen an sich oft auch äh mit sich tragen, zumindest was man jetzt sozusagen aus diesem islamistischen Terror herauskennt
nicht wahr? Ähm oder oder sagen wir mal auch aus dem Rechtsterror herausgehen. Wir hatten das ja in in Schweden auch.
Dass äh dass er so sozusagen als Erfolg gefeiert wird, sozusagen als Person auch irgendwie sichtbar zu werden. Und in dem Moment, wo man eben dieser Anerkennung, versagt, ist sicherlich auch schon mal ein Schritt getan worden in die richtige Richtung.
Und wenn man sich einfach nur anschaut, eben was das Umfeld des Täters war, die um die Altersstruktur dort. Ich glaube schon, dass das auch ganz wichtig ist, ähm wie man jetzt mit so einem Fall umgeht, ob der Nachahmer findet oder nicht,
Also wenn das die Community ist, aus der heraus so ein Anschlag ähm passiert, muss man sich genau das A anschauen und.
Die werden ja wahnsinnig leicht zu fassen gewesen. Schon allein irgendwie,
die Slowakei ist wirklich so, dass dass Näheste, wo man von Wien aus hinfahren kann, das ist Bratislava, ja, also ähm und dass man halt einfach nur dort probiert Waffen zu kaufen, das eh scheitert, weil's rechtlich gar nicht geht.
Nicht einmal dann.
Schaut man sich diese Leute näher an. Also es ist auch wirklich so ein Systemversagen des Geheimdienstes. Ich glaube auch, dass deswegen, äh, wenn die jetzt mit mehr Überwachung kommen oder mit ähm die Ausländer sind Schuld.
Na, ihr seid schuld. Also der Geheimdienst hat einfach verkackt und das ist sie offensichtlich und darüber müssen wir reden.
Ich glaub wir haben in der Sendung über den BVT-Skandal unter der türkisblauen Regierung geredet, also als die FPÖ, die rechtsextreme noch an der Macht war in Österreich, hat man ja eine Hausdurchsuchung beim Inlandsgeheimdienst gemacht.
Was auch mit einem enormen Vertrauensverlust anderer Länder in unser Sicherheitssystem einhergegangen ist. Also wir sind aus einigen Kooperationen rausgeflogen.
Also ähm man kann auch sozusagen bei der FPÖ nach Schuld suchen, die den Geheimdienst ähm vielleicht in seiner Struktur zerstört hat. Da gab's ewig lange Kragen und Streitereien und glaube ich immer noch einen parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss.
Also ähm ja. Österreich macht hier keine gute Figur auf der offiziellen Seite, auf der menschlichen Seite,
ähm bin ich positiv überra.
Ich auch.
Sind wir uns einig. Ähm ich, dann, dann würde ich weitergehen und also wir bleiben beim Terror, aber wir wechseln die Ebene und zwar auf EU-Ebene.
Ich will nur ein kurzes Update geben und einen Aufruf starten. Patrick Breyer hat ja hier in der Sendung Exzellent schon informiert über die Verhandlungen zu Terrist Content Regulation, kurz TCO,
Ähm und äh Linus hat auch in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung, glaube ich, das CCC zu dem Thema nochmal äh Referenziert,
und da will ich einfach nur sagen, es geht jetzt in die letzten Meter der Verhandlungsebene, also nächste Woche ist wieder eine Trilog.
Runde, also äh das heißt, da werden da verhandeln, die EU-Mitgliedsstaaten mit dem Parlament und der Kommission über das finale Gesetz und man ist sehr nah einem Abschluss.
Jeder Druck, den wir jetzt noch irgendwie auf die Abgeordneten im Europaparlament äh richten können, ist sehr, sehr hilfreich,
Also das ist genau der Moment, wo,
euer Anruf bei den Abgeordneten, wo eure E-Mail, eure Tweet oder euer Facebook-Post an die Abgeordneten auf ihrer Wall wirklich noch mal einen Unterschied machen kann,
wir verlinken hier nochmal einige Quellen, unter anderem auch ein PDF mit dem Verhandlungsteam.
Das sind die Leute, die wirklich am Tisch sitzen werden nächste Woche. Und wer noch irgendwie ein paar Stunden übrig hat im Lockdown, ähm und.
Da eine Meinung dazu hat, jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt, um die noch zu äußern.
Und sowas kann wirklich ein Unterschied machen. Also wenn Abgeordnete mitbekommen, dass hier wirklich ein Interesse von der Bevölkerung da ist, dass es keine Uploadfilter gibt.
Zum Beispiel oder dass diese Löschanordnungen aus anderen EU-Staaten wirklich sauber gemacht sind,
nicht die ungarische Zensurbehörde dann überall Löschanordnungen hinschicken darf,
Da sollte man sich wirklich jetzt noch äußern. Äh das Parlament hat eigentlich eine sehr gute Position, die darf es nur nicht verlieren, also da darf es nicht äh zu viele Konzessionen machen,
an den Ratern, die Mitgliedsstaaten und an die Kommission. Also da ähm,
ist noch ein Zeitfenster, weil man sich aktivieren will. Da muss man nicht auf die Straße gehen, das kann man auch von zu Hause aus machen. Wer noch Motivation braucht oder ein bissel Adrenalin, äh wir verlinken hier auch noch ein Video von der europäischen Volkspartei,
mit sehr schönen Aussagen wie lange hat's gedauert bis Facebook das Christchurch Video runtergenommen hat.
Internet. Ähm also da ist ganz viel an äh ja sehr, sehr, sehr ähm.
Ideologie von der Volkspartei dabei und äh die sind aber zum Glück nicht diejenigen, die
den Berichterstatter stellen, also die hauptsächlich verhandeln für das Dossier, dass es jemand von ECR, also von der polnischen Pisspartei ähm und äh die, wie gesagt, die Verhandler haben wir verlinkt, dass es auf jeden Fall was, wo
ähm ja, man jetzt doch einen Unterschied machen kann.
Wo sollte man sich denn beschweren oder sein äh seinen Kommentar abgeben?
Also in dem PDF, was wir verlinkt haben, habt ihr alle ähm Verhandlerinnen drinnen.
Und genau dort würde ich äh nachschlagen. Ich habe jetzt eben nur die Leute im Kopf, die eh schon auf unserer Seite sind.
Auch zu lange her ist, dass ich selber dort angerufen habe. Äh es ist ähm boah, mein Gott, diese Namen. Äh Marina äh Caliurand äh ist die Abgeordnete der Sozialdemokraten.
Mein Gott, nee, diesen Namen kann ich nicht aussprechen, von für einen Liberalen, also FDP ist es, Malte Bagazau, Retone Duo. Mein Gott.
Und ähm.
Kommt der Name her?
Grünen, ich habe kein Griechisch,
Griechen, das äh ähm und und äh sie ist selber auch, sie hat selber auch schon mal einen Terranschlag in ihrer Familie gehabt, deswegen war's nicht ganz so einfach, mit ihr zu reden,
Aber man muss ja halt erklären, dass es hier nicht um, man tut dem Terror nichts Gutes, wenn man anfangt, Dinge im Internet zu zensieren. Also ähm die, die Radikalisierung kriegt man nicht weg, indem man jetzt Welt Uploadfilter überall hinpflanzt. Das hat andere Gründe.
Ähm ja und für die Linken ist Cornelia Ernst äh zuständig, die auch aus Deutschland kommt. Aber ich glaube, die muss man nicht überzeugen.
Also wer mit ähm der Sozialdemokratie, den Liberalen oder mit nochmal reden will, der hätte dort auf jeden Fall noch eine Chance, einen Unterschied zu machen.
Ich äh kann da nur nochmal auch auf unsere äh Stellungnahme hinweisen oder unsere Pressemitteilung, die wir dazu veröffentlicht hatten. Und ja.
Ich kann nur daran erinnern, wir hatten den Titel nicht schon wieder Upload-Filter. Die Argumente sind also es ist sehr, leider, leider, sehr ermüdend.
Umso wichtiger, dass sich da jetzt auch vielleicht entweder Leute, die darin schon geübt sind, mit wenig Aufwand nochmal in die Diskussion einbringen. Das hat ja bei der Urheberrechtsreform auch funktioniert oder eben welche, die es noch nicht gemacht haben
haben jetzt wirklich fertige.
Ähm ja, wie Thomas schon sagte, fertige Argumente da liegen. Es ist, es ist im Prinzip einfach, das ist, das können wir aus der Schublade holen.
Genauso wie es da leider auch passiert ist.
Ganz genau,
Also und äh der Blogpost von Patrick Breyer, den wir hier auch nochmal verlinken, der hat auch wirklich die aktuellsten Informationen dazu. Da seht ihr genau, was gerade der Verhandlungsstand auf beiden Seiten ist,
und äh wenn man sich das einmal durchliest, dann ist man eigentlich perfekt gebrieft für diese Gespräche und ähm selbst entweder direkt mit den Verhandlern sprechen oder mit Leuten in deren Partei,
Abgeordnete können sich auch gut gegenseitig lobbyieren, wenn man da irgendwo einen Draht.
Würde ich weitergehen und äh euch noch berichten, was äh ich diesen Sommer so gemacht habe in Österreich gab's nämlich ein Hass im Netzpaket.
Mit einem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz und einigen anderen sehr problematischen Themen.
Ich glaube, darüber haben wir noch nie gesprochen. Ähm also es begab sich so, dass im,
Juni uns klar wurde, es wird ein Netz DG in Österreich geben, also ein Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz wie in Deutschland auch, mit dem online Plattformen dazu verpflichtet werden, innerhalb einer vorgefassten Frist von vierundzwanzig Stunden oder sieben Tagen,
gemeldete Inhalte zu löschen, wenn diese denn illegal sind. Ähm das Ganze aber auf eine Art, die sehr einseitig ist, wo man eigentlich als Plattform,
wenn man ökonomisch handelt immer mal lieber löscht und eigentlich nur was zu befürchten hat wenn man nicht löscht,
äh etwas oben zu lassen, ist da äh eben nicht wirklich im eigenen Interesse der Plattform. Genau dieses Problem hat sich Österreich importiert.
Diesem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz. Es gab dann über den Sommer sehr heiße Verhandlungen. Ähm es gab einen gemeinsamen Brief mit der Wikipedia, den wir verfasst haben.
Und einige Ausarbeitungen für die Verhandler und äh inzwischen ist das Gesetz aber,
veröffentlicht worden und die kritischen Stimmen haben sich gemehrt also von der Richtervereinigung angefangen über,
ähm Betroffenen Plattformen, also Crowdfunding Plattformen sind auch von dem Ding betroffen, E-Learning-Plattformen.
Und wir haben da zum Glück einige Stimmen mobilisiert bekommen in Österreich, die auch zeigen, wie groß der Kollateralschaden ist von den Dingen, also,
ähm dieses Gesetz sieht vor, dass man eben bis zu zehn Millionen Euro Strafe zu befürchten hat,
Plattform muss einen Verantwortlichen, Beauftragten nennen und wenn diese Person nicht zu jeder Zeit erreichbar ist, gibt's persönliche Strafen für sie, von äh zehntausend Euro.
Also das ganze Gesetz ist so geschrieben als wär's eben wirklich nur für Google und Facebook ausgerichtet. Es trifft aber auch wirklich viele andere Plattformen,
die die auch mit Userterated Content arbeiten, aber überhaupt kein Problem von Hass im Netz haben.
Und man kann's vielleicht am schönsten zusammenfassen, die kommen aus, die Medienregulierungsbehörde in Österreich, also die Stelle, die mit diesem Gesetz mehr Geld und mehr Macht bekommt.
Hat auch eine Stellungnahme abgegeben, die es zehn Seiten lang und vernichtend. Also die sagt so, verwendet so Wörter wie, das ist realitätsfremd. Dies führt zu Rechtsunsicherheit. Also.
Da da ist eindeutig sehr geschlammt worden und ähm das Schöne ist, dieses Gesetz wird jetzt auf EU-Ebene diskutiert, also solche Maßnahmen, wenn ein Mitgliedsstaat das Internet regulieren will,
das wissen vielleicht nicht alle da müssen die der EU angezeigt werden,
es gibt das sogenannte Trisssystem. Fragt mich jetzt nicht, wozu wofür Stress steht, aber TRIS ist so eine Datenbank, wo man sich all diese Gesetze anschauen kann,
und auch ähm dort eben äh Stellungnahmen abgeben kann und das passiert jetzt, dass immer mehr Institutionen sich dieses österreichische Gesetz anschauen,
Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen und sagen, oh mein Gott, bitte nicht. Ähm und äh ja, bis zum zweiten Dezember kann man sich dort noch einbringen. Wir werden das mit Ederi gemeinsam machen.
Und ähm ja, haben auch noch Hoffnung, dieses dieses ähm Netz, die gehen in Österreich zu verhindern.
Ähm da gibt's aber noch andere Teile von diesem Gesetzespaket, die ich auch noch kurz erwähnen will und zwar gibt es äh ja, um Österreicher eine Regierung aus Konservativen und Grünen.
Das Netzige kommt von den Konservativen. Die Grünen haben auch.
Äh Vorschlag gemacht, der Hass im Netz äh in Österreich irgendwie bekämpfen soll, also da geht's ganz viel eben um Hate Speech gegen Frauen, gegen Minderheiten, rassistische Rölperser und derlei mehr.
Nur leider ist bei diesem Gesetz der Grünen doch aus einiges dabei, was wir aus Netzpolitischer Sicht kritisieren müssen, also unter anderem Netzsperren.
Lassen oder wenn da ein einzelner Blogpost drinnen ist, der einem nicht gefällt.
Man muss vorher nicht irgendwie versuchen, den zuerst löschen zu lassen. Man kann einfach eine Unterlassung erwirken gegen den Internet Provider und da muss der da sperren.
Ähm selbiges kann auch hergenommen werden, um Uploadfilter zu machen. Also um.
Inhalte, wie zum Beispiel beleidigend sind gegen eine Person,
da eine Unterlassung zu erwirken gegen eine Plattform und dann sind diese Inhalte nicht nur einmal weg, sondern es muss ein Notes-und Stay down passieren, also ich darf das nicht nochmal posten dort.
Die Plattform das zulassen würde, dann äh wäre sie haftbar dafür. Also das ist auch etwas, dass man nur mit technischen Filtern,
implementieren kann. Österreich bezieht sich da auf ein EuGH-Urteil ähm Cawisnik, versus Facebook, Kaffeestück war mal die Chefin der grünen Partei, die hat gegen Facebook gewonnen.
Und das will man jetzt hier implementieren und äh das heißt auch Uploadfilter für jede Art von Plattform,
Deswegen ist unter anderem die Wikipedia auch in dem Thema ein Allianzpartner von uns, weil die auch sagen, hey, wir haben keine Upload-Filter, wir können das gar nicht, was sie hier rechtlich fordert.
Ähm mal schauen, ob die Grünen an dem auch festhalten. Ähm und da gibt's noch irgendwie zwei andere obskurritäten.
Ähm wenn man jemanden verklagen will wegen einem Privatanklagedelikt, also es ist jetzt was äh wo wo keine Staatsanwaltschaft aktiv wird, aber,
wo ich eine Person eben, weil sie meinen Ruf geschädigt hat oder Kreditfähigkeit geschädigt hat, klagen will.
Dann ähm muss ich das ja gegen eine Person machen, wenn ich aber nur ein anonymes Posting habe, kann ich nicht klagen,
Dieses Problem haben die Grünen sich vorgestellt. Man könnte doch irgendwie zu Gericht gehen und äh noch bevor man eine Privatanklage einreicht, mal so Beweisanträge stellen, dass man jemanden ausforschen will.
Dann könnte man ja irgendwie mal schauen, wer steckt hinter dieser IP-Adresse? Lokalisieren wir doch mal diese IP-Adresse,
geben wir gleich noch ein paar andere Überwachungsmethoden dazu, zum Beispiel das sicherstellen von Geräten oder äh die Anlassdatenspeicherung, also das komplette Aufzeichnen von Kommunikationsprofilen, wer wann mit wem gesprochen hat.
Und eben auch die Inhaltsüberwachung, also extrem weitreichende Überwachungsmethoden werden Leuten eröffnet.
Bevor sie überhaupt eine Anklage eingebracht haben. Also eigentlich nur zum Ausforschen des Täters und man wird aber nicht nur den Namen des Täters, sondern halt wirklich alle Daten,
daraus geforscht wurden. Was halt supergroße Rechtsschutzprobleme mit sich bringt,
und ja, also das ist auch so eines der Themen, wo wir Probleme sehen
Insgesamt haben wir uns keine Freunde bei den Grünen gemacht die Partei hatte früher sehr viele positive netzpolitische Positionen aber bei dem Gesetz haben sie echt geschlampt, das ist echt schlecht gemacht und deswegen haben wir auch Kritik geübt
die ähm hoffentlich dazu führt, dass sich bei dem Gesetz noch was ändert.
Im Dezember ist auch dieses Gesetz von der EU stillhalte Notifizierung befreit und dann werden wir eine Debatte haben, ähm die hoffentlich produktiv verläuft.
Kurzer Nachtrag, Twist steht für Technikal Ranger Regulation Information. So ein schöner Gummi Gummibegriff.
Das machen jetzt alles nur, weil der Ben irgendwie ein paar weiß Haus und Regierungsmitarbeiter köpfen möchte oder was.
Ja auch ein bisschen übertrieben, ne.
Völlig ohne Anlass.
Okay, dann äh würde ich sagen, kommen wir zu unserer Corona-Warn-App. Da hat äh die Webseite Business Insider jetzt die,
Pläne veröffentlicht, äh was da so oder irgendwie in ihre Finger bekommen und daraus berichtet, was da jetzt in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten.
Ins Haus steht und ähm.
Tja, ich denke, das ist ein bisschen äh Underwellming, wenn ich ehrlich sein soll. Ähm wir haben erstens so ein,
habe ich das mal genannt. Also sie haben ja festgestellt, dass lediglich sechzig Prozent der Nutzerinnen ihr Ergebnis auch auch geteilt haben und damit andere Nutzer gewarnt haben, ja? Und,
Mir ist irgendwie, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt, sage ich mal, gerade mal sechzig Prozent der Leute sagen, ah ja, Corona-App total geil. Ich mache auch mal eine Warnung
ja
Äh ich glaube, das liegt wahrscheinlich eher an dieser fehlenden Laboranbindung und dem Gehhampel mit der Teletannen. Ja, als dass es jetzt daran lege, dass die Leute sagen, nee, das mache ich aber jetzt nicht so, ne? Das kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen. Auf jeden Fall wollen sie jetzt äh zum Ende November ein Update machen.
Was dann irgendwie auch erinnert, wenn man also
ein Testergebnis hat, dass man das irgendwie mitteilen soll. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie sich das oft positiv und negativ verteilen soll, aber okay, das werden sie tun. Ich glaube eher, dass es ein UX-Problem ist, als ein Motivationsproblem, aber okay.
Ist das eigentlich äh ist es eine ist das sozusagen eine Gerüchteliste oder ist das schon sogar Form bestätigt worden, dass das auch so ist?
Die zitieren aus konkreten Plänen der Bundesregierung, die verschriftlich sind.
Okay.
Das, was ich so gehört habe, damit deckt sich das auch. Ähm er Version eins Punkt sieben, ebenfalls Ende November wollen sie.
Den ähm Datenabgleich häufiger machen, was sehr sinnvoll ist, ne? Also man darf ja nicht vergessen, die App holt sich neue Notif
Notification Anlässe nur alle vierundzwanzig Stunden, was theoretisch.
Mindestens.
Zu einer Verzögerung von fast achtundvierzig Stunden führen kann, ne, wenn deine ähm wenn du quasi abholst, kurz nachdem.
Ähm oder oder wenn wenn eingereicht wird, kurz nachdem du abgeholt hast. Ach nee, nee, kann nur zu vierundzwanzig Stunden Verzögerung führen. Das ist aber viel genug für eine App, die schnell äh dafür äh sorgen soll, ne. Dann sollen die Kontaktzeiten.
Warte mal kurz dazu, meines Wissens, ist das eine Beschränkung des Fremworks gewesen? Dass sozusagen diese Vergleiche,
Also du kannst natürlich öfter die Schlüssel abholen, aber du konntest halt auch nur innerhalb von vierundzwanzig Stunden einen so einen Vergleich durchführen. Und ich vermute mal, dass das äh,
quasi ein Rickfest ist bei Apple und Google das zu ändern und das äh ich weiß bin mir jetzt gerade nicht so sicher, ob das schon geändert wurde. Ich,
glaube ja, dass das sozusagen jetzt öfter gemacht werden kann und jetzt wird es halt auch in die App eingebaut.
Auf jeden Fall sinnvoll. Dann äh.
Irgendwie ab Februar einundzwanzig soll sich dann ändern, dass man eine Historie mit Risikobegegnungen angezeigt bekommt, so dass ich nachvollziehen lässt, äh wann genau es zu einer Infektion gekommen sein könnte,
Das finde ich irgendwie eine überraschende Darstellung, weil also zumindest die,
Bei den roten Warnungen jagen schon der die Zeit angezeigt wird. Die soll aber jetzt eben noch noch klarer sein, dass man dann eben genauer angezeigt bekommt dann und dann war das so. Ähm.
Auch das von mir aus, ja.
Also auch die mit dem niedrigen Risiko. Das ist ja derzeit das Problem, dass man da überhaupt gar keine zeitliche Information bekommt.
Na ja doch, du kriegst ja gesagt, an welchem Tag das war. Also ja, ist in Ordnung. Ich glaube, also ist eine Änderung, ganz ehrlich, die wird jetzt
da wird das Coronavirus jetzt nicht großartig drunter leiden, ja? Das habe ich ja schon öfter mal erklärt. Das ist sicherlich interessant für die Leute,
das zu sehen, ja? Das also es ist eine größere Beschwerde, eine häufige Beschwerde der Leute, dass sie nicht genau wissen, wann ihre Niedrigrisiko-Begegnung war. Das kriegen sie jetzt angezeigt. Das wird aber jetzt nicht zum Durch,
in der Pandemie führen. Was durchaus wichtig ist, was wir ja auch schon öfter gefordert haben, ist eben, dass Kontakttagebuch.
Da schreibt Business Insider ab Februar einundzwanzig, also ziemlich genau zum Ende der,
der ausgesperren, so ungefähr, ja. Ähm oder Shutdowns oder Lockdowns. Leute, bitte äh eine eine kleine Bitte,
lass uns da jetzt nicht Haare spalten, jeder weiß, was mit dem Lockdown light gemeint ist, der wird nun mal so genannt. Wir wurden jetzt darauf hingewiesen, dass das aber ein Shutdown sei, ähm,
Von mir aus ist es auch ein Shutdown. Ich lese überall Lockdown light, also verwende ich auch diesen Begriff. Äh bitte korrigiert diejenigen, die sich den ausgedacht haben.
Ähm genau, also ein Kontakttagebuch soll jetzt Ende Februar einundzwanzig integriert werden, um eben die Nachverfolgung von ähm.
Dazu ähm äh zu verbessern.
Es wäre schön, wenn das so gemacht wurde, wie es jetzt hier eben von dem Team, was DP3T sowieso erfunden hat, auch vorgeschlagen wurde, genauso wie wir das auch ähm.
Hier schon vor ein paar Wochen empfohlen haben, wo ich den Begriff der Zusammenkunft genannt habe, aber,
Leider sieht es nicht danach aus, dass es so getan wird, denn ich finde danach hier diese Empfehlung mit dem gleichen Update im Februar einundzwanzig soll außerdem.
Das Öffnen für externe Dienstleistungsangebote geplant sein. Ähm dahinter steckt
nach Informationen vom Business Insider DE, dass beispielsweise Nutzer bei einem Restaurantbesuch auf das mitunter als lässig empfunden ausfüllen von Zetteln, verzichten
können. Stattdessen würden sie in dem Lokal über einen QR-Code einchecken und die Corona-Warn-App würde darüber informiert werden. Ähm.
Da steckt jetzt viel Interpretationsraum drin, ja? Wenn das mit einem QR-Code funktioniert, könnte das ein sinnvolles System sein, was eben alle anderen so kaputten und
zentralen, externen Dienstanbieter für corona-Warnlisten, obsolet machen würde,
so wie es da steht, klingt es aber irgendwie so, als würde ein Interface für diese kaputten und unsicheren Systeme geschaffen werden, was exakt der G, das Gegenteil von dem wäre, was äh sinnvoll ist. Ja, ähm.
Leider kann ich da, aber da habe ich da bisher noch nicht genauere konkrete Informationen gefunden, sodass mich hier das, was Business Insider schreibt und zitiert, dann doch ähm relativ,
ähm ja äh misstrauisch stimmt, dass dass da gerade in die richtige Richtung geht. Allerdings äh sind die Beschreibungen,
ungenau genug, um um wirklich zu interpretieren, was es jetzt bedeuten soll und was nicht. Ich vermute aber, dass sich da relativ schnell ähm.
Von der einen oder der anderen Seite irgendwie nochmal eine Erläuterung.
Bekomme, was damit genau gemeint ist. So wie's da steht, klingt es erstmal nicht besonders gut. Und außerdem wollen sie,
ja App und Pandemiestatistiken integrieren in die App das schon ab Dezember so dass man dann irgendwie von der App also dass sie mehr,
tagtäglichen Nutzen hat, ja? Ähm auch irgendwie Texte ins französische, russische und arabische übersetzt. Ähm.
Ich denke, was also irgendwie schöne Grafiken darzustellen ist sicherlich eine eine auch eine sinnvolle Sache.
Besondere von vor ein paar Monaten, als wir noch das größere Chaos hatten mit,
welche Regeln in welchem Bundesland gelten. Das wäre auch eine sehr schöne Sache, dass überhaupt an irgendeiner Stelle mal klar äh aufgearbeitet zu haben, redaktionell, wo man sagen kann, zum Beispiel jo, bin ich ähm.
Bin ich Berlin
Willig, München, ne, wie viel, was was sind meine Reiseoptionen, was darf ich, was darf ich nicht? Ähm das wäre alles sehr schön und denke, äh bei einem Projekt, was jetzt inzwischen an den zwanzig Millionen schrappt, auch,
durchaus zumutbar.
Zumal es die anderen Apps äh in anderen Ländern ja auch schon vormachen, wie das geht. Also bei der irischen App, da hast du diese ganze Statistik-Information einfach vom Staat weg.
Was ich nicht sehe, ist der der Durchbruch, dass hier mal die Funktionalität tatsächlich erweitert wird vor,
Februar und äh das äh nenne ich dann insgesamt ähm kann ich da jetzt keinen,
Schritte erkennen. Das ist alles nice to have und das wird auch sicherlich schön und gut, aber was wir eigentlich bräuchten, wäre halt diese Clustererkennung und die hätten wir schon vor Monaten gebraucht ähm und die kriegen wir halt jetzt im Monaten.
Tja.
Ich finde das schon mal eine gute Nachricht, dass überhaupt noch an dieser App weitergearbeitet wird.
Stimmt, da kriegen wir noch ein bisschen was für unser Herz kosten tut sie ja. Jetzt wird auch noch was gemacht. Ist gut.
Das wird sicherlich auch noch mehr kosten, als es bisher gekostet hat. Das ist ja auch in Ordnung. Sollen Sie meinetwegen auch äh Geld dafür bekommen, Hauptsache es kommt auch was und ich finde, so Februar ist ein bisschen so Februar irgendwie, das ist.
Das ist nicht ambitioniert.
Dass es noch lange hin, also das das muss äh für diese für diese Art Features, von denen wir jetzt hier sprechen,
weiß ich nicht, finde ich das ein bisschen lamaschig.
So, dann haben wir äh gestern beschlossen.
Du hast das beschlossen.
Beschlossen vom Bundestag. Und zwar die.
Die Speicherung von Fingerabdrücken im Personalausweis. Und zwar ist es so, dass es äh zwanzig neunzehn eine Verordnung des EU-Parlamentes zur Erhöhung der Sicherheit der Personalausweise und der Aufenthaltsdokumente
gab, ja, die mit einer knappen Mehrheit beschlossen wurde. Zwanzig neunzehn im EU-Parlament. So, jetzt wird, um dieser Verordnung zu entsprechen.
Die Speicherung von zwei Fingerabdrücken im Speichermedium des Personalausweises verpflichtend.
Und das Passbild, was da drin ist, muss,
digital erstellt und durch eine sichere digitale Übermittlung an die Passbehörde gesendet werden,
Ähm und bei dieser Übermittlung wird dann auch die Biometrie tauglichkeit geprüft.
Damit soll vorgebeugt werden, dass du einen Ausdruck des Bildes mitbringst, der in irgendeiner Form,
manipuliert wurde, als wenn das vor dieser digitalen Übertragung nicht passieren könnte. Ähm es ist außerdem eine erweiterte Möglichkeit der Lichtbildaufnahme in Behörden vorgesehen.
Also dass du ähm dass die quasi sicherstellen können, dass du ein ordentliches Bild dort hast. Da haben sie noch ein bisschen darüber diskutiert, was das für die ähm Fotostudios bedeutet,
Entscheidend ist an dieser ganzen Entscheidung ähm Folgendes. Man hat jetzt also noch Zeit bis zum zweiten August zwanzig einundzwanzig. Personalausweise ohne Fingerabdrücke zu beantragen.
Und warum sollte man das tun? Nun, wir erinnern uns an die Debatte.
Zugriffs auf die Bilder. Ja, es war, wir haben zwanzig siebzehn. Die Debatte darüber geführt,
dass Polizei und Geheimdienste automatisch auf die biometrischen Passbilder von äh Personalausweisen zentralisiert,
zugreifen dürfen. Und zwar mit keiner nennenswerten Kontrolle und keinen nennenswerten Aufsichtsbehörden. Das war ein großes Versprechen, dass das nicht der Fall werden würde,
mit der Einführung dieser Systeme. Das ging dann relativ schnell, dass man gesagt hat
Nein, biometrische Passbild kommt nur in den Pass und dann ging's irgendwie so, ja, dann durften die Polizeibehörden drauf zugreifen und dann durften sie, haben sie auch noch eine zentrale Stelle bekommen, damit sie's schneller hinkriegen, ne? Damit hatten wir dann letztendlich den Punkt, dass für eine
automatisierte Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum. In spätestens zehn Jahren die Datenbank eben bereit steht, weil die Polizei ähm.
Auf diese Daten zugreifen kann. Es steht zu erwarten,
dass das für Fingerabdrücke natürlich genauso kommen wird in einiger Zeit, dass man dann irgendwie sagen will, naja, wer also wir haben ja eigentlich die Fingerabdrücke von allen
äh Bundesbürgerinnen und Bundesbürgern. Und jetzt haben wir hier einen Fingerabdruck, wissen nicht, wem der gehört. Das wäre doch echt spitze, wenn wir in diese Datenbank zugreifen können. Ja? Ähm.
Es kann doch nicht sein, dass na, das kann doch nicht sein, dass die Polizei aber keine Zugriffe drauf hat.
Ich verlinke dazu einmal äh die Meldung des Bundestags, ähm in dem die Entscheidung bekannt gegeben wird, dann gab es eine äh Stellungnahme von Friedemann Ebelt heißt er, glaube ich, von der ähm,
äh Organisation Digitalcourage, der da eine äh ordentliche Stellungnahme zu verfasst hat, die bei uns verlinkt ist und ich verlinke auch nochmal eben die,
Stellungnahme zwanzig siebzehn zum Thema EID, wo es um diesen um diese Ausweitung.
Des Zugriffs ging. Keine besonders.
Ja keine besonders schöne Entwicklung, dass wir dann jetzt hier nämlich eine Massen, wirklich eine massenhafte Erfassung von biometrischen Daten und.
Eben den Fingerabdrücken haben. Und das ist äh das tja,
das ist genau das, was wovor eben vor Jahren dann gewarnt wurde und das
Das schleicht sich dann eben nach und nach ein. Wenn ihr erstmal die Dinger hasst, für die meisten Leute macht's
halt wenig Unterschied, ihnen am Anfang zu sagen, hier übrigens, wenn du jetzt deinen Fingerabdruck äh auf diesen Leser hältst, dann wird der nur in dem Personalausweis gespeichert und dann wird eben ein paar Jahre später gesagt, ach,
stellt sich raus, wir haben da noch so eine Datenbank, da müssen jetzt weitere darauf zugreifen, ne. Das ist und noch dazu, ne, Fingerabdruck, auch davor haben wir immer gewarnt, aber der Fingerabdruck ist eben für viele Endgeräte.
Laptops, Smartphones, ein Authentizierungsmerkmal, ja? Das heißt, äh wenn ihr so ein ähm Personalausweis
dann merkt euch wenigstens die Finger und lernt in euren äh Smartphones andere Finger ein als die von denen ihr bereits eine kopiefähige Erfassung
beim Start hinterlegt habt.
Bezüglich der Verwendung von so ähm biometrischen Pastas,
habe ich auch eine schöne Anekdote ähm äh ein neues Bildungsdokumentationsgesetz in Österreich, das wir letzte Woche äh kommentiert haben, sieht auch den Zugriff auf die biometrischen Gesichtsbilder aus der Pastdatenbank
äh vor, ähm aber für Schulen und Unis.
Also die dürfen jetzt für das Ausstellen von äh Schülerinnen und Studierendenausweise ähm auch auf diese Daten zugreifen. Ähm was auch äh crazy ist, weil da nun,
nun natürlich auch die Tür geöffnet wird für ähm Gesichterkerlung an den Schulen und schon allein, dass du irgendwie deine Passbilder dann auf diesen Schülerausweisen hast. Ähm es ist einfach wieder ein neues Missbrauchspotenzial, was geschaffen wird.
Ähm und auf EU-Ebene wird das Thema übrigens auch diskutiert, da gab es vor ein paar Wochen jetzt Bewegung äh bei der I das Verordnung, also dem europäischen äh Level an an Identität
dass es im Moment ein Serlax ist, dezentrales System und das soll scheinbar auch zentralisiert werden. Da gab's ähm
auch grade wieder Bestrebungen und es findet sich auch im Arbeitsprogramm der EU-Kommission, dass der Rechtsrahmen auf EU-Ebene ähm bezüglich solcher Sachen reformiert wird.
Ähm dann würde ich weiterkommen zum elektronischen Impfpass, oder?
Habt ihr sowas?
Ja, ähm also das ist so äh sehr heikles Thema. Ich glaube
äh in der Sendung haben wir schon mehrmals über Immunitäts äh Ausweise gesprochen und diese Idee des Corona-Hotels und
Das hier ist sowas ähnliches, aber nicht genau dasselbe. Also ähm Impfpässe kennt man vielleicht. Das sind diese,
glaube ich im internationalen Feld gelben Broschüren, wo jede Impfung eingetragen wird und dann,
ähm braucht man das teilweise auch, wenn man sich für gewisse Jobs bewirbt oder in manchen Ländern einreisen will, wo wo man äh eben die richtigen Impfungen braucht
Ja und jetzt äh ist halt auch jemand hergegangen und hat gesagt, hey, aber es wäre doch toll, wenn wir das elektronisch erfassen würden. Also wenn wir eine zentralisierte Datenbank machen,
wo alle Impfungen, ähm die irgendjemand bekommt, gespeichert sind. Ähm diese.
Dieses Projekt wurde ähm schon letztes Jahr zwanzigneunzehn gestartet und im im Jenna endet auch die Begutachtung für das Gesetz. Äh und jetzt in der Pandemie wurde das aber beschleunigt vorangetrieben,
und seit ähm Oktober ist dieses Register auch schon am Netz und es werden auch schon Impfungen äh gespeichert,
jetzt in diesem Fall noch nicht von allen Hausärzten und allen Apotheken,
ähm sondern jetzt in der Pilotphase erstmal nur von äh gewissen Grippeimpfaktionen, die es in äh Österreich gibt, vor allem bei der Stadt Wien gibt's eine große, die auch gratis ist. Und ähm,
Da werden eben sozusagen,
Impfungen gespeichert, dass die Begründung äh wieso man das elektronisch braucht, ist eben öffentliche Gesundheit. Also Ziel des Projekts sei eine verbesserte Impfversorgung der Bevölkerung,
die Schaffung einer genauen Datenbasis zur Steuerung der Gesundheit, des Gesundheitswesens. Und am Ende will man natürlich auch ähm Optimierungspotential schaffen.
Das große Problem ist hierbei, ähm
dass dieses Register verpflichtend ist. In Österreich gibt es schon ähm ein System genannt, das ist eine elektronische Gesundheitsakte. Ähm darin werden schon ähm alle Befunde von Ärzten gespeichert und auch Medikamente, die einem verschrieben werden
und es gibt äh eine Möglichkeit, sich von diesem System abzumelden und über dreihunderttausend Leute haben das in Österreich auch getan.
Ähm und hier gibt es diese Möglichkeit aber nicht. Und äh das äh dieser fehlende Opt-out äh ist auch,
auf mehreren Ebenen ein Problem, weil ähm.
Wir haben in unserem äh Statement äh so schön gesagt, bisher hatten Impfgegner keinen guten Grund, sich nicht impfen zu lassen, aber wenn man jetzt aus Datenschutzgründen sagt,
Ich will aber nicht in diesem Register stehen,
ähm ist es problematisch. Für für uns wär's okay gewesen, wenn man sagt, das Ding ist wirklich nur für Fremd für Impfungen gegen Fremdgefährden der Krankheiten.
Oder wenn man sagt, es ist jetzt mal nur für die Pandemie beschränkt und wir reden danach nochmal drüber, aber in der Pandemie brauchen wir sowas vielleicht, weil die Impfung äh mehrere Dosen hat und wir das irgendwie logistisch steuern wollen.
Hätte ja sein können, aber das hier ist ein System, das permanent äh geplant ist,
wo wir eben glauben, es äh braucht weitaus bessere Möglichkeiten, die Kontrolle für die einzelne Person aufrechtzuerhalten,
und äh wenn wir dann angefangen haben damit uns zu beschäftigen, gab's dann auch eine Journalistin, die,
bei der Stadt Wien angefragt hat und da ist ein schöner Schnitzer passiert,
die Stadt Wien hat diese Impfaktion wo man sich Köppe impfen lassen kann und wir hatten im Oktober auch eine Wahl in Wien, wo der Bürgermeister neu gewählt wurde,
und äh vor der Wahl,
Würde diese Anfrage, ob seinen Opt-out gibt, äh beantwortet mit, ja, natürlich gibt es einen Opt-Out für dieses System und nach der Wahl
die Journalistin dann nochmal nachgefragt und die Antwort war so richtig ups, da ist dem Kollegen wohl ein K ausgekommen, natürlich gibt es keinen Opt-Aut. Äh,
Ist halt auch äh wir verlinken den Artikel.
Also du fragst dich doch.
Ehrlich, ne? Da draußen stehen irgendwie die Leute mit ihren Impfzwangen, Fantasien und ihren und die noch nicht gechipten flippen aus und so, ne? Und.
In so einer Zeit machst du dann irgendwie ein elektronisches Verfahren zur Erfassung deines Immunstatus ohne äh oder was. Also manchmal fragst du dich doch wirklich.
Also selbst wenn ein solches System zu Vorteilen in den Prozessen führen würde, die man jetzt noch nicht hätte, was ich sowieso schon in Zweifel ziehe, aber dann, selbst wenn es diese gäbe, sind sie auf jeden Fall eher gering.
Und dann stellst du dir doch echt noch die Frage so, hm, was kostet dieser Kram an an Vertrauen? Ähm.
Und und an Verschwörungstheorien und sonstigen, was jetzt hier irgendwie losgetreten wird. Allein deshalb würde man doch sagen, vielleicht entscheiden wir sowas nicht im November zwanzig zwanzig.
Wenigstens so viel würde ich doch erwarten, oder?
Ja, also ich ich halt's auch für denkbar unglücklich, was du gesagt hast, stimmt absolut, das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung ist grade die höchste Währung in dieser Krise.
Ich weiß gar nicht, welche Krise. Egal, welche Krise es ist, es ist auf jeden Fall.
Jeder Krise, in jeder.
Ähm und vor dem Hintergrund, ja
Also ich ich habe auch echt Angst davor, dass ähm man das jetzt wirklich als Argument verwendet, um sich nicht impfen zu lassen und mir wurde das von teilweise von
politischer Seite auch so kommentiert, na ja, aber es gibt ja einen, man kann sich ja nicht impfen lassen.
Das darf nicht die Antwort sein. Das darf nicht die Antwort sein.
Oh Mann, ey. Oh.
Den ja?
Ja, also.
Oje.
Es wird irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich fühle mich gerade sehr dystopisch. Ähm machen wir Schluss.
Also ich auch noch mal kurz was zu sagen. Also das ist ja immer so dieses Problem, hatten wir ja auch schon mal im anderen äh Kontext so,
selbst wenn du's jetzt gut meinst, ne, als Regierung. Und ich kann ja durchaus verstehen, dass man gerade bei dieser ganzen Impfgeschichte mal gerne einen Überblick hätte. Weil das Thema ist ja nun auch ein bisschen heiß, aber ist auch ganz praktische,
Frage, sagen wir mal, jetzt Bereitstellung von Grippeimpfstoff. Wie viel braucht man? Ah nee, das keine äh fällt mir gerade ein, keine gute,
keine gute Idee, weil äh das sich ja jedes Jahr ändert, ne, aber sozusagen Masern äh Prophylaxe, du willst halt einfach wissen, wie wie durchgeimpft ist denn sozusagen die Bevölkerung? Und dann sind natürlich solche Daten,
wertvolles Planungsmaterial. Aber es ist natürlich auf der anderen Seite auch so. Wir wissen,
Es ziehen aber nicht alle Leute mit und wenn man dann so eine Argumentation aufmacht mit so einer wenn du dich nicht impfst, dann wirst du auch nicht gespeichert.
Nee, also ganz schlechter Stil.
Ja, ich ich glaube, es wird halt einfach nicht
äh erkannt, dass es dass es hier also man hätte das ja auch mit gelinderen Mitteln machen können, dass zum Beispiel Leute, die wirklich den Opt-Art machen, zumindest statistisch noch erfasst werden. Das ist dann halt ohne Personenbezug
Ähm und man hat einfach nur ähm.
Grafischen Daten, sodass man's wirklich nicht zurückführen kann und ob jetzt diese ob jetzt so eine Person geimpft ist oder nicht, weil die statistische Auswertung, äh die ist im Gesetz sowieso dann ohne Personenbezug definiert.
Ich glaube, darum geht's ihnen hauptsächlich. Ähm die medizinische Anwendung, ob jetzt mein Arzt sehen kann, ob ich geimpft bin oder nicht. Ich glaube, da muss man einfach auf die ähm
Verantwortlichkeit der Leute setzen und ähm dann hast du halt irgendwie noch diesen gelben Impfpass und musst den halt auf Papier mitbringen,
das ist jetzt auch keine Hexereise, ich mein wir haben's die letzten Dekaden auch super geschafft mit
diesen Systemen und nur weil eine Optimierung denkbar ist, heißt das nicht, dass man ähm alles andere aus dem Fenster rauswerfen muss, nur um äh das System in diese Richtung umzubauen.
Ja, also das, das wird uns auch noch ein bissel begleiten. Aber uns war's wichtig, keine Impfgegner auf unserer Seite zu holen, sondern wir wollen Leute, die,
sich impfen lassen und denen Datenschutz wichtig ist, für die muss es eine Option geben.
Genau. Einen äh Hinweis in eigener Sache.
Noch zum äh Schluss, ich sehe mich genötigt mein primäres Spendenkonto zu ändern, weil die Bank der Meinung ist.
Bei so vielen Buchungen müsste sie mehr vom Kuchen abbekommen.
Das sehe ich natürlich anders, aber das ist alles nicht so erfreulich. Sprich, ich wollte mich jetzt hier mal an die Leute wenden, die dankenswerterweise,
Podcast und die Mieterebene mit äh regelmäßigen Kleinstspenden,
ähm unterstützen, also Daueraufträge eingerichtet haben, was beileibe mir die liebste Form der Unterstützung ist, weil's halt kontinuierlich ist und äh die Planbarkeit einfach enorm erhöht.
Ähm und ich möchte mich jetzt sozusagen an euch wenden und äh euch bitten, doch bitte diesen Dauerauftrag so ihr denn eingerichtet habt,
auf ein neues Konto umzuziehen. Ich weiß, das ist,
bei manchen Banken ein ganz schöner äh Terror, ja, sich da mit diesen Online-Banking Interfaces und Hans und was nicht alles, äh was einem dann noch für merkwürdige Steine in den Weg gelegt werden,
Damit äh klarzukommen, aber äh das wäre doch sehr äh hilfreich. Hm
ich habe dazu noch einen längeren Post gemacht, da äh steht alles drin, wer's äh schnell und einfach haben möchte, kann einfach auf der verlinkten Spendenseite die ganzen neuen Kontaktdaten finden und äh.
Würden uns natürlich auch freuen, wenn ihr dann auch nochmal aktualisiert, welche Podcasts ihr denn gerne unterstützen und hören möchtet, also zum Beispiel wenn LNP unterstützt, dann schreibt doch LNP mit rein.
Und.
Ist wichtig. Das ist das ist mir wichtig.
Das ist äh Linus ganz wichtig.
Dann kriege ich nämlich was ab, sonst nicht.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Aber Tim, äh ganz ehrlich, äh du konntest dir natürlich keine bessere Sendung aussuchen als die nachdem wir
äh gesagt haben, dass wir hier einen Podcast machen äh ohne fünf Mal am Tag auf äh mit irgendwie Werbung einzuspielen und sonstiges. Und,
vor einer Hörerschaft, ja, die dann kritisch anmerkt, ja, natürlich in der letzten Sendung
gesagt habe, wir betteln hier nicht die ganze Zeit um Spenden. Ja, die dann sagt, naja, Entschuldigung, vor einhundertvier Sendungen in der Folge zweihundertzweiundsechzig, ähm hat der Tim ja durchaus gesagt, man könne ihm Geld spenden, ja? Und.
Damit muss ich jetzt leben. Also, wenn ihr alle mitmacht, dann erhalte ich auch erstmal wieder das Maul. Kein Problem.
Schweigegeld, genau, das ist Schweigegel.
Stimmt, das ist eigentlich die beste Form des Schweigegeldes einfach. Das äh ne.
Schön ausgeglichen Geisteszustand habt ihr da. Ihr wollt doch nicht, dass da mit irgendwas kommt. Hm.
Ähm na ja. Genau, aber egal, schreibt da ruhig mal mit rein. LNP und so. Hm, das passt dann schon.
Okay, aber das ist tatsächlich ein ein riesen Problem, ne, weil äh also Erhöhung, die Erhöhung von Bankgebühren, die hier bei Tim ist dann doch nennenswert. Äh vor allem, was die äh kleinen Kleinspenden angeht, ähm
und dann ist das genau deshalb machen die sowas ja auch, ne? Genau deshalb machen die das ja und sagen.
Großteil der Großteil der Spenden liegt halt irgendwie äh unter fünf Euro so, ne und wenn da halt irgendwie jetzt so ein Euro kommt äh pro Monat und dann geht da irgendwie äh fünfundzwanzig Prozent davon einfach gleich wieder an die Bank, so
das ist gar nicht gut so. Da äh habe ich einfach wenig Verständnis ähm dafür und ähm ja, also ihr könnt dann halt sozusagen
aufs Konto umziehen und ja, wenn er in dem in dem Schritt dann auch mal über eine Aufrundung äh nachdenkt, dann habe ich auch nichts dagegen.
Sich äh wird sich der ohnehin äh übrigbleibende äh Verlust, weil alle werde ich jetzt in der kurzen Zeit nicht erreichen können. Ähm sich in Grenzen hacken.
Echt fünfundzwanzig Cent für eine SEEPA Buchung, das ist ja wirklich äh.
Eingehend.
Ja, also Wahnsinn. Sehbar ist doch gerade deswegen toll, weil's Money Transfer ist. Also wir wir haben das.
Doch nicht, dass dass man das ist so, heißt doch nicht, dass für uns toll sein muss, das heißt, dass für die Banken toll sein muss.
Das alte Zinsmodell funktioniert halt jetzt seit längerer Zeit nicht mehr und deswegen sind sie dann natürlich jetzt hinterher, ne, wie die Wilden
und äh ja, dementsprechend muss ich hier mal meine Strategie an äh passen, ne? Leider gibt's sowas wie äh.
Auf äh Kontonummern leider nicht. Ja, fanden das würde es natürlich einfach machen, ne?
Forward machen ist gar kein Problem, Tim, zahlst du einfach nur mal für jede ausgehende Buchung Nummer fünfundzwanzig.
Ja aber
wieso wieso eigentlich so Einziehungsaufträge das ist wie wie wir es bei Episenter Works machen und wie auch wie Max es macht
mit Noib. Äh das braucht natürlich ein System dahinter, wo du dann strukturiert diese Mandate auch hast, aber ja.
Genau deswegen nicht. Ich will den Aufwand äh äh möglichst gering halten und das auch alles so äh freiwillig halten so und äh ich glaube, dass
Das Modell funktioniert so ganz gut so. Wer keinen Bock mehr hat, lässt es halt einfach sein, passt es an. Ähm das ist alles freiwillig und so wird's halt auch bleiben.
Super, dann wäre ich noch kurz äh mit dem danken dran. Und zwar danke ich Jani, Stefan, Tim und Michael.
Und ich danke Thomas, dass du äh hier zu uns in die Sendung gekommen bist mit all den ganzen äh Updates.
Nils schleicht die. Arschloch.
Also wenn das nicht der Sendung.
Das ist übrigens mein Lieblings äh Schimpfwort geschissener. Ja, das finde ich viel besser. Da kannst du wirklich sagen, das ist eine äh eine eine eigenes österreichisches Wort, ohne Entsprechung.
Ähm ja, ich meine, es gibt das Originalvideo, wo das gefallen sein soll. Habe ich nicht gesehen. Ich glaube, das ist auch nicht mehr im Netz, aber die es gibt da eine Überlieferung von und das kommt mir als Wiener auch am realistisch,
vor, wenn das wirklich.
Ist.
Der heilige Dreifaltigkeit.
Okay.
Haben wir das ja geklärt. Alle anderen, ihr seid, wir haben euch alle lieb. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.